.
WELCOME TO GOOGLE I/O16!
THANK YOU FOR COMING. WE
HOPE
YOU ENJOY THE NEXT THREE
DAYS. IT'S GOING TO BE WARM
SO PLEASE BE SURE TO KEEP
HYDRATED!
GOOGLE I/O IS OUR ANNUAL
DEVELOPER FESTIVAL WITH HANDS-ON
LEARNING, TECHNICAL TALKS, AND
A CHANCE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT G
OOGLE'S LATEST
DEVELOPER PRODUCTS.
#IO16
.
WELCOME TO GOOGLE I/O 2015
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
WE HOPE YOU ENJOY THE NEXT
THREE DAYS.
IT'S GOING TO BE WARM, SO
PLEASE BE SURE TO KEEP
HYDRATED!
GOOGLEGOOGLE I/O IS OUR ANNUAL
DEVELOPER FESTIVAL WITH
HANDS-ON LEARNING, TECHNICAL
TALKS, AND A CHANCE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT GOOGLE'S LATEST
DEVELOPER
PRODUCTS.
#io16
[ MUSIC ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Sundar Pichai: WELCOME.
WELCOME TO GOOGLE I/O.  AND
WELCOME TO SHORELINE.  IT
FEELS REALLY NICE AND
DIFFERENT UP HERE.  WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS IN MOSCONE, AND IN
FACT, WE'VE BEEN DOING I/O
FOR 10 YEARS BUT I FEEL WE
ARE AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN
TERMS OF WHERE WE ARE GOING
AS A COMPANY AND FELT IT
APPROPRIATE TO CHANGE THE
VENUE.
DOING IT HERE ALSO ALLOWS US
TO INCLUDE A LOT MORE OF YOU.
THERE ARE OVER 7,000 OF YOU
JOINING IN PERSON TODAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND LATER TODAY, AFTER THE
KEYNOTE, YOU'LL BE JOINED BY
SEVERAL GOOGLERS, PRODUCT
MANAGERS, ENGINEERS, AND
DESIGNERS, SO HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL ENGAGE IN MANY, MANY
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE THREE
DAYS.
AS ALWAYS, I/O IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THE
LARGEST-EVER AUDIENCE.  WE
ARE LIVE STREAMING THIS TO
530 EXTERNAL EVENTS IN OVER A
HUNDRED COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD, INCLUDING DUBLIN,
WHICH IS A MAJOR TECH HUB IN
EUROPE.
[ CHEERS ]
ISTANBUL, WHICH IS OUR OLDEST
GOOGLE DEVELOPER GROUP.
[ CHEERS ]
AND EVEN TO COLOMBO
SRI LANKA, WHICH IS THE
LARGEST OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH 2,000
PEOPLE.
[ CHEERS ]
OUR LARGEST DEVELOPER
AUDIENCE ON THE LIVE STREAM
IS FROM CHINA TODAY WITH OVER
1 MILLION PEOPLE TUNING IN
LIVE FROM CHINA, SO WELCOME
TO THOSE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE LIVE IN VERY, VERY
EXCITING TIMES.  COMPUTING
HAS HAD AN AMAZING EVOLUTION.
STEPPING BACK, LARRY AND
SERGEY FOUNDED GOOGLE 17
YEARS AGO WITH THE GOAL OF
HELPING USERS FIND THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED.  AT
THE TIME, THERE WERE ONLY
300 MILLION PEOPLE ON LINE.
MOST OF THEM WERE ON BIG
PHYSICAL COMPUTERS, ON SLOW
INTERNET CONNECTIONS.
FAST-FORWARD TODAY.  THANKS
TO THE RATE AT WHICH
PROCESSORS AND SENSORS HAVE
EVOLVED, IT IS TRULY THE
MOMENT OF MOBILE.  THERE ARE
OVER 3 BILLION PEOPLE
CONNECTED AND THEY ARE USING
THE INTERNET IN WAYS WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE.  THEY LIVE
ON THEIR PHONES.  THEY USE IT
TO COMMUNICATE, LEARN NEW
THINGS, GAIN KNOWLEDGE,
ENTERTAIN THEMSELVES.  THEY
TAP AN ICON, EXPECT A CAR TO
SHOW UP.  THEY TALK TO THEIR
PHONES AND EVEN EXPECT MUSIC
TO PLAY IN THE LIVING ROOM.
OR SOMETIMES GROCERIES TO
SHOW UP AT THE FRONT DOOR.
SO WE ARE PUSHING OURSELVES
REALLY HARD SO THAT GOOGLE IS
EVOLVING AND STAYING A STEP
AHEAD OF OUR USERS.
ALL THE QUERIES YOU SEE
BEHIND ME ARE LIVE QUERIES
COMING IN FROM MOBILE.  IN
FACT, TODAY, OVER 50% OF OUR
QUERIES COME FROM MOBILE
PHONES.  AND THE QUERIES IN
COLOR YOU SEE BEHIND ME ARE
VOICE QUERIES.  IN THE U.S.,
ON OUR MOBILE APP IN ANDROID,
ONE IN FIVE QUERIES -- 20% OF
OUR QUERIES -- ARE VOICE
QUERIES AND THAT SHARE IS
GROWING.  GIVEN HOW
DIFFERENTLY USERS ARE
ENGAGING WITH US, WE WANT TO
PUSH OURSELVES AND DELIVER
THEM INFORMATION, RICH
INFORMATION, IN THE CONTEXT
OF MOBILE.
THIS IS WHY, IF YOU COME TO
GOOGLE TODAY AND SEARCH FOR
BEYONCE, YOU DON'T JUST GET
TEN BLUE LINKS.  YOU GET A
RICH INFORMATION CARD WITH
MUSIC.  YOU CAN LISTEN TO HER
SONGS, FIND INFORMATION ABOUT
UPCOMING SHOW EVENTS, AND
BOOK IT RIGHT THERE.  YOU CAN
COME AND ASK US DIFFERENT
QUERIES.  PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS OR CHAMPIONS
LEAGUE, AND WE AGAIN GIVE YOU
RICH IN-DEPTH INFORMATION.
AND WE DO THIS ACROSS
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CATEGORIES GLOBALLY AT SCALE.
YOU CAN COME TO GOOGLE
LOOKING FOR NEWS AS WELL.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN HYPERLOOP, AN
EXCITING TECHNOLOGY, WE GIVE
YOU INFORMATION WITH AMP
RIGHT THERE IN SEARCH RESULTS
AND THEY LOAD INSTANTLY AND
YOU CAN SCROLL THROUGH THEM.
AMAZING TO SEE HOW PEOPLE
ENGAGE DIFFERENTLY WITH
GOOGLE.  IT'S NOT JUST ENOUGH
TO GIVE THEM LINKS.  WE
REALLY NEED TO HELP THEM GET
THINGS DONE IN THE REAL
WORLD.
THIS IS WHY WE ARE EVOLVING
SEARCH TO BE MUCH MORE
ASSISTIVE.  WE'VE BEEN LAYING
THE FOUNDATION FOR THIS FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS THROUGH
INVESTMENTS IN DEEP AREAS OF
COMPUTER SCIENCE.  WE BUILT
THE KNOWLEDGE GRAPH.  WE
TODAY HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING
OF 1 BILLION ENTITIES.
PEOPLE, PLACES, AND THINGS.
AND THE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
THEM AND THE REAL WORLD.  WE
HAVE DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED
THE QUALITY OF OUR VOICE
RECOGNITION.  WE RECENTLY
STARTED TRAINING OUR DATA
SETS WITH NOISY BACKGROUNDS
DELIBERATELY, SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR PEOPLE MORE ACCURATELY.
THE QUALITY HAS IMPROVED
RECENTLY BY 25%.
IMAGE RECOGNITION AND
COMPUTER VISION.  WE CAN DO
THINGS WHICH WE NEVER THOUGHT
WE COULD DO BEFORE.  IF
YOU'RE IN GOOGLE PHOTOS
TODAY, AND YOU SEARCH FOR
HUGS, WE ACTUALLY PULL AN ALL
THE PICTURES OF PEOPLE
HUGGING IN YOUR PERSONAL
COLLECTION.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE HAVE RECENTLY EXTENDED
THIS TO VIDEOS, SO YOU CAN
SAY "SHOW ME MY DOG VIDEOS"
AND WE ACTUALLY GO THROUGH
YOUR VIDEOS AND PULL OUT YOUR
FAVORITE VIDEOS.
TRANSLATION.
10 YEARS AGO, WE COULD
TRANSLATE, MACHINE-TRANSLATE
IN TWO LANGUAGES.  TODAY WE
DO THAT FOR OVER A HUNDRED
LANGUAGES AND EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE TRANSLATE OVER
140 BILLION WORDS FOR OUR
USERS.
WE EVEN DO REALTIME VISUAL
TRANSLATION.  IF YOU'RE A
CHINESE USER AND YOU RUN INTO
A MENU IN ENGLISH, ALL YOU
NEED TO DO IS TO HOLD UP YOUR
PHONE AND WE CAN TRANSLATE IT
INTO ENGLISH FOR YOU.
PROGRESS IN ALL OF THESE
AREAS IS ACCELERATING, THANKS
TO PROFOUND ADVANCES IN
MACHINE LEARNING AND AI, AND
I BELIEVE WE ARE AT A SEMINAL
MOMENT.
WE AS GOOGLE HAVE EVOLVED
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE PAST
10 YEARS AND WE BELIEVE WE
ARE POISED TO TAKE A BIG LEAP
FORWARD IN THE NEXT 10 YEARS.
SO LEVERAGING OUR
STATE-OF-THE-ART CAPABILITIES
IN MACHINE LEARNING AND AI,
WE TRULY WANT TO TAKE THE
NEXT STEP IN BEING MORE
ASSISTIVE FOR OUR USERS.  SO
TODAY, WE ARE ANNOUNCING THE
GOOGLE ASSISTANT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SO WHAT DO WE MEAN WHEN WE
SAY "THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT"?
WE WANT TO BE THERE FOR OUR
USERS ASKING THEM, "HI, HOW
CAN I HELP?"  WE THINK OF THE
ASSISTANT IN A VERY SPECIFIC
WAY.  WE THINK OF IT AS A
CONVERSATIONAL ASSISTANT.  WE
WANT USERS TO HAVE AN
ONGOING, TWO-WAY DIALOGUE
WITH GOOGLE.  WE WANT YOU TO
HELP GET THINGS DONE IN YOUR
REAL WORLD AND WE WANT TO DO
IT FOR YOU, UNDERSTANDING
YOUR CONTEXT, GIVING YOU
CONTROL OF IT.  WE THINK OF
THIS AS BUILDING EACH USER
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL GOOGLE.
WE ALREADY HAVE ELEMENTS OF
THE ASSISTANT WORKING HARD
FOR OUR USERS.  I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT 20% OF QUERIES
ON OUR MOBILE APP IN ANDROID
IN THE U.S. ARE VOICE
QUERIES.  EVERY SINGLE DAY,
PEOPLE SAY OKAY, GOOGLE.  AND
ASK US QUESTIONS THAT WE HELP
THEM WITH AND WE HAVE STARTED
BECOMING TRULY CONVERSATIONAL
BECAUSE OF OUR STRENGTHS IN
NATURAL LANGUAGE PROCESSING.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU CAN BE IN
FRONT OF THIS STRUCTURE IN
CHICAGO AND ASK GOOGLE, "WHO
DESIGNED THIS?"  YOU DON'T
NEED TO SEE "THE BEAN" OR
"THE CLOUD GATE."  WE
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONTEXT AND
WE ANSWER THAT THE DESIGNER
IS ANEARBY ANISH KAPOOR.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE.  YOU
CAN ASK GOOGLE, "WHO DIRECTED
THE REVENANT?"
>>Google: THE RELEVANT WAS
DIRECTED BY.
>>Sundar Pichai: AND YOU CAN
FOLLOW UP THAT WITH A
QUESTION SHOW ME HIS WORDS.
BECAUSE I FIND THAT NAME
VERY, VERY HARD TO PRONOUNCE.
AND GOOGLE COULD PICK THAT
CONVERSATION UP AND RETURN
THE RIGHT ANSWER.
THIS HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
REALLY HARD TO DO FOR
COMPUTERS.  THE REASON WE ARE
ABLE TO DO IT IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE INVESTED THE LAST DECADE
IN BUILDING THE WORLD'S BEST
NATURAL LANGUAGE PROCESSING
TECHNOLOGY.  IN OUR ABILITY
TO DO CONVERSATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING IS FAR AHEAD OF
WHAT OTHER ASSISTANTS CAN DO.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT
FOLLOW-ON QUERIES, OUR
STUDIES SHOW THAT WE ARE AN
ORDER OF MAGNITUDE AHEAD OF
EVERYONE ELSE.
SO TODAY PEOPLE ARE USING
GOOGLE AND ASKING US
QUESTIONS IN MANY, MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS, SO WE'VE PUT
TOGETHER A SHORT VIDEO SO
THAT YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK.
[ VIDEO PLAYING ]
[ MUSIC
]
OKAY, GOOGLE., SHOW ME THE
TRAILER FOR ANGRY BIRDS.
>>> FIRE!
>>> HOW OLD IS THE TAJ MAHAL?
WHOA.  TAKE ME THERE.
>>> HERE ARE SOME HEADLINES.
>>> WHAT'S PICASSO'S FULL
NAME?
>>> PABLO DIEGO JOSÉ
FRANCISCO DE PAULA JUAN
NEPOMUCENO MARÍA DE LOS
REMEDIOS CIPRIANO DE LA
SANTÍSIMA TRINIDAD RUIZ Y
PICASSO.
>>> YOU'RE ON THE FASTEST
ROUTE.
>>> PLAY LAUGHING OWL.
[ LAUGHING OWL ]
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE., I'M ON A
THAT SELL.
>>> HELLO.
>>> SHOW ME MY GRADUATION
PHOTOS.
>>> ON MY BLOG.
>>> IT'S 29 DEGREES AND
CLEAR.
>>> YOUR ORDER HAS SHIPPED.
>>> HERE ARE YOUR SCORES.
[ VIDEO CONCLUDES
]
[ CHEERS ]
>>Sundar Pichai: AS YOU CAN
SEE, USERS ARE ALREADY
LOOKING TO GOOGLE TO GET --
TO HELP THEM GET THINGS DONE,
BUT WE BELIEVE WE ARE JUST
GETTING STARTED.  WE BELIEVE
THIS IS A LONG JOURNEY AND
GIVEN IT'S A JOURNEY, WE WANT
TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE FUTURE.  WE WANT TO
SHOW YOU THE KIND OF THINGS
WE ASPIRE TO BE ABLE TO.
LET ME DO THAT WITH AN
EXAMPLE.
HERE'S A COMMON SITUATION.
IT'S A FRIDAY NIGHT.  I'M
SURE MANY OF YOU CAN RELATE
TO IT.  BACK HOME, I WANT TO
TAKE MY FAMILY TO A MOVIE.
YOU KNOW, YOU NORMALLY PULL
OUT YOUR PHONE, RESEARCH
MOVIES, LOOK AT THE REVIEWS,
FIND SHOWS NEARBY, AND TRY TO
BOOK A TICKET.
YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO BE THERE
IN THESE MOMENTS HELPING YOU.
SO YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO ASK
GOOGLE, "WHAT'S PLAYING
TONIGHT?"  AND BY THE WAY,
TODAY, IF YOU ASK THAT
QUESTION, WE DO RETURN MOVIE
RESULTS, BUT WE WANT TO GO A
STEP FURTHER.  WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONTEXT AND
MAYBE SUGGEST THREE RELEVANT
MOVIES WHICH YOU WOULD LIKE
NEARBY.
I SHOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
IT AND MAYBE TELL GOOGLE, "WE
WANT TO BRING THE KIDS THIS
TIME."  AND THEN IF THAT'S
THE CASE, GOOGLE SHOULD
REFINE THE ANSWER AND SUGGEST
FAMILY-FRIENDLY OPTIONS.
AND MAYBE EVEN ASK ME, "WOULD
YOU LIKE FOUR TICKETS TO ANY
OF THESE?"
AND IF I SAY, "SURE, LET'S DO
JUNGLE BOOK," IT SHOULD GO
AHEAD AND GET THE TICKETS AND
HAVE THEM READY WAITING FOR
ME WHEN I NEED IT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AS YOU CAN SEE, I ENGAGED IN
A CONVERSATION WITH GOOGLE
AND IT HELPED ME GET THINGS
DONE IN MY CONTEXT.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS IS JUST
ONE VERSION OF THE
CONVERSATION.  THIS COULD
HAVE GONE MANY, MANI'
MANY, MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.  FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN GOOGLE RETURNED THE
RESULTS, I COULD HAVE ASKED,
"IS JUNGLE BOOK ANY GOOD?"
AND GOOGLE COULD HAVE GIVEN
ME THE REVIEWS AND MAYBE EVEN
SHOWN ME A TRAILER.  AND BY
THE WAY, I SAW THE MOVIE.
IT'S TERRIFIC.  AND HOPE YOU
GET TO SEE IT AS WELL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
EVERY SINGLE CONVERSATION IS
DIFFERENT.  EVERY SINGLE
CONTEXT IS DIFFERENT.  AND WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO DO THIS
FOR BILLIONS OF
CONVERSATIONS, FOR BILLIONS
OF USERS AROUND THE WORLD,
FOR EVERYONE.
WE THINK OF THE ASSISTANT AS
AN AMBIENT EXPERIENCE THAT
EXTENDS ACROSS DEVICES.  I
THINK COMPUTING IS POISED TO
EVOLVE BEYOND JUST PHONES.
IT WILL BE IN THE CONTEXT OF
A USER'S DAILY LIFE.  IT WILL
BE ON THEIR PHONES, DEVICES
THEY WEAR, IN THEIR CARS, AND
EVEN IN THEIR LIVING ROOMS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF YOU'RE IN ONE
OF THE HUNDRED DIFFERENT
ANDROID AUTO MODELS AND
YOU'RE DRIVING AND YOU SAY,
"LET'S HAVE CURRY TONIGHT,"
WE KNOW THE WARRIORS ARE
TONIGHT AND STEPH CURRY IS
PLAYING BUT YOU KNOW ALL
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IS FOOD,
AND WE SHOULD BE SMART AND
LET YOU KNOW WHEN IT IS READY
AND MAYBE EVEN HAVE IT
WAITING FOR YOU AT YOUR HOME.
TALKING ABOUT YOUR HOME,
WE'VE ALREADY BUILT MANY,
MANY PRODUCTS FOR YOUR HOME.
TODAY, WE HAVE SOLD OVER
25 MILLION CHROMECAST
DEVICES, SO WE'VE BEEN
THINKING HARD ABOUT HOW TO
BRING THIS VISION OF GOOGLE
ASSISTANT INTO YOUR HOME.
CREDIT TO THE TEAM AT AMAZON
FOR CREATING A LOT OF
EXCITEMENT IN THIS SPACE.
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT OUR
OWN UNIQUE APPROACH AND WE
ARE GETTING READY TO LAUNCH
SOMETHING LATER THIS YEAR.
TO GIVE YOU A PREVIEW, I'M
GOING TO INVITE MARIO FROM
THE CHROMECAST TEAM.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Mario Quieroz:
THANKS,
SUNDAR.  TODAY WE WANT TO
GIVE YOU AN EARLY PREVIEW OF
HOW WE'RE BRINGING THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT TO THE HOME.
OUR AS ASPIRATION IS TO MAKE
THE
ASSISTANT USEFUL AND
ENJOYABLE IN ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PLACES IN YOUR
WORLD:  WHERE YOU SPEND TIME
WITH YOUR FAMILY.  WHEN I
WALK INTO MY HOUSE, I WANT TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT, BUT I SHOULD BE
ABLE TO INTERACT WITH IT IN A
HANDS-FREEWAY, SIMPLY USING
MY VOICE WITHOUT HAVING TO
TAKE OUT MY PHONE.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE CREATING
GOOGLE HOME, A DEVICE WHICH
WILL BE AVAILABLE LATER THIS
YEAR.
GOOGLE HOME LETS YOU ENJOY
MUSIC AND ENTERTAINMENT
THROUGHOUT YOUR ENTIRE HOUSE,
MANAGE EVERYDAY TASKS MORE
EASILY, AND ASK GOOGLE WHAT
YOU WANT TO KNOW.
ALL OF THIS WILL BE DONE BY
SPEAKING WITH THE ASSISTANT.
IT WILL LET ANYONE IN THE
FAMILY, KIDS OR ADULTS, HAVE
A CONVERSATION WITH GOOGLE.
GOOGLE HOME IS UNMATCHED IN
FAR-FIELD VOICE RECOGNITION
SINCE ITS POWERED BY MORE
THAN TEN YEARS OF INNOVATION
IN NATURAL LANGUAGE
PROCESSING.
I CAN CONTINUE THE TWO-WAY
DIALOGUE WITH THE ASSISTANT
THAT SUNDAR MENTIONED
EARLIER, WHETHER I'M STANDING
NEARBY COOKING DINNER OR
SITTING ACROSS THE ROOM
PLAYING A GAME WITH MY
DAUGHTER.
WITH GOOGLE HOME, WE SET OUT
TO CREATE AND DESIGN A
BEAUTIFUL PRODUCT THAT'S WARM
AND INVITING AND FITS
NATURALLY IN MANY AREAS OF
THE HOME.
WE'RE DESIGNING THE TOP TO
BLEND INTO YOUR HOME.  WE'LL
GIVE YOU THE OPTION TO
CUSTOMIZE THE BASE WITH
DIFFERENT COLORS AND
FINISHES, INCLUDING METAL AND
FABRIC TO REFLECT YOUR HOME'S
STYLE, WHETHER IT BE IN THE
LIVING ROOM, THE KITCHEN, OR
THE
BEDROOM.
WE'RE PUTTING A LOT OF
CRAFTSMANSHIP INTO THE
HARDWARE DESIGN, INCLUDING
THE LEDs'S PLACEMENT AND
CHOREOGRAPHY, THE SPEAKER
WHICH WILL FILL YOUR ROOM
WITH MUSIC, THE MICROPHONE
SYSTEM, AND THE CLEAN FACE
WITHOUT ANY
BUTTONS.
.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
THIS IS GOOGLE HOME!
WE THINK IT WILL BE A
BEAUTIFUL ADDITION TO ANY
ROOM IN YOUR HOUSE.  AND
WE'RE EVEN MORE EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT IT'S GOING TO DO FOR
YOU.
FIRST, MUSIC AND
ENTERTAINMENT ARE A BIG PART
OF WHAT MAKES BEING AT HOME
RELAXING AND FUN.  NOT LONG
AGO, WE INTRODUCED
CHROMECAST, DESIGNED TO PLAY
YOUR FAVORITE SHOWS, MOVIES,
AND YOUTUBE VIDEOS ON THE
BIGGEST SCREEN IN YOUR HOUSE.
LAST YEAR, WE ADDED
CHROMECAST AUDIO TO BRING THE
EUSK YOU LOVE TO YOUR BEST
SPEAKERS.
CHROMECAST HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE HOTTEST-SELLING CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS PRODUCTS SINCE
THE DAY IT LAUNCHED, AND
GOOGLE HOME WILL BUILD ON
THOSE EXPERIENCES.
GOOGLE HOME IS A WI-FI
SPEAKER THAT STREAMS MUSIC
DIRECTLY FROM THE CLOUD SO
YOU GET THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PLAYBACK.
IT WILL DELIVER RICH BASS AND
CLEAR HIGHS ALL FROM A
BEAUTIFUL, COMPACT FORM
FACTOR.
OF COURSE YOU CAN ACCESS
SONGS, PLAYLISTS, ALBUMS,
ARTISTS, AND PODCASTS FROM
YOUR FAVORITE MUSIC SERVICES
JUST BY ASKING WITH YOUR
VOICE.
OR IF YOU PREFER, YOU CAN
SEND MUSIC FROM YOUR ANDROID
OR iOS DEVICE THROUGH
GOOGLE CAST.  AND UNLIKE
OTHER HOME ASSISTANTS, GOOGLE
CAST SUPPORT ALLOWS YOU TO
CONTROL OTHER SPEAKERS IN
YOUR HOME, WITHOUT
COMPLICATED SETUP.
SO WHEN YOU WANT TO LISTEN TO
COLDPLAY IN THE LIVING ROOM
SPEAKERS, YOU CAN SIMPLY SAY,
"PLAY VIVA LAVIDA" IN THE
LIVING ROOM AND IT WILL START
PLAYING.  CAST SUPPORT ALSO
ENABLES MULTI-ROOM PLAYBACK
SO YOU CAN ADD ONE OR MORE
GOOGLE HOME DEVICES TO A
GROUP OF SPEAKERS AND REALLY
BLAST YOUR FAVORITE TUNES.
AND IT LETS YOU CONTROL YOUR
VIDEO CONTENT, TOO.  LET'S
SAY THAT YOU WANT TO WATCH
THAT EPISODE OF JIMMY KIMMEL
OR THE TRENDING YOUTUBE VIDEO
ON YOUR TV.  JUST TELL GOOGLE
HOME, AND THE CONTENT WILL
APPEAR ON THE BIGGEST,
BRIGHTEST SCREEN IN YOUR
HOUSE.
NEXT, GOOGLE HOME WILL BECOME
MORE AND MORE OF A CONTROL
CENTER FOR YOUR WHOLE HOME.
HOME IS WHERE LOTS OF DAILY
TASKS JUST NEED TO GET DONE.
HAVING ACCESS TO THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT MAKES THIS A LOT
EASIER.  IT'S LIKE HAVING A
VOICE-ACTIVATED REMOTE
CONTROL TO THE REAL WORLD
WHENEVER YOU NEED IT.  YOU
CAN DO THE BASICS LIKE
SETTING ALARMS AND TIMERS OR
MANAGING TO-DO LISTS AND
SHOPPING LISTS.  WE'RE ALSO
DESIGNING GOOGLE HOME TO
CONNECT YOUR SMART HOME
SEAMLESSLY.  IT WILL SUPPORT
THE MOST POPULAR HOME
NETWORKING SYSTEMS SO THAT
YOU CAN EASILY CONTROL YOUR
LIGHTS, THERMOSTATS,
SWITCHES, AND MORE, INCLUDING
OUR OWN NEST DEVICES.
FURTHER IN THE FUTURE, WE'LL
WORK WITH DEVELOPERS TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE TO CONTROL THINGS
BEYOND THE HOME, LIKE BOOKING
A CAR, ORDERING DINNER, OR
SENDING FLOWERS TO MOM, AND
MUCH, MUCH MORE, ALL WITH
JUST YOUR VOICE.
THIRD, GOOGLE HOME LETS YOU
ASK GOOGLE ABOUT ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO KNOW.  OF COURSE YOU
CAN GET THE BASICS LIKE THE
WEATHER OR FACTS THAT YOU
MIGHT FIND ON WIKIPEDIA.  BUT
WHAT MAKES GOOGLE HOME REALLY
SHINE IS THAT IT HAS SEARCH
BUILT IN.
IT DRAWS ON 17 YEARS OF
INNOVATION IN ORGANIZING THE
WORLD'S INFORMATION TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WHICH ARE DIFFICULT
FOR OTHER ASSISTANTS TO
HANDLE.  YOU MIGHT ASK:  HOW
MUCH FAT IS IN AN AVOCADO?
OR:  WHAT IS DRAYMOND GREEN'S
JERSEY NUMBER?  AND THEN
FOLLOW-UP THAT LAST QUESTION
WITH WHERE DID HE GO TO
COLLEGE?  OR TRY SOMETHING
MORE COMPLEX.  WHAT WAS THE
U.S. POPULATION WHEN NASA WAS
ESTABLISHED?
YOU'LL GET IMMEDIATE,
ACCURATE ANSWERS FROM GOOGLE
EACH TIME.
AND THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT NOT
ONLY KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THE
WORLD, BUT IT WILL STAND
APART IN HOW IT CAN ALSO GET
TO KNOW YOU OVER TIME.  WITH
YOUR PERMISSION, OF COURSE.
IT CAN HELP YOU RETRIEVE YOUR
TRAVEL ITINERARY, YOUR DAILY
SCHEDULE, YOUR TRAFFIC TO
WORK, YOUR PACKAGE DELIVERY
INFORMATION, AND MUCH MORE.
AND AS GOOGLE KEEPS GETTING
BETTER, SO WILL GOOGLE HOME.
SO THAT'S GOOGLE HOME.  A
BEAUTIFUL, SMART,
VOICE-ENABLED ASSISTANT FOR
THE WHOLE FAMILY.  ENJOY
MUSIC AND ENTERTAINMENT
THROUGHOUT YOUR ENTIRE HOUSE,
MANAGE EVERYDAY TASKS
EFFORTLESSLY, AND ASK GOOGLE
WHAT YOU WANT TO KNOW.
IT'S EARLY DAYS, BUT WE WANT
TO GIVE YOU AND SHOW YOU HOW
WE ENVISION THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT COMING TO LIFE AT
HOME.  WE CREATED A SHORT
VIDEO TO BRING THE PRODUCT
INTO A FAMILY SETTING TO
CAPTURE WHAT IT MIGHT BE LIKE
IN THE FUTURE TO HAVE YOUR
PERSONAL GOOGLE AROUND THE
HOUSE.
LET'S ROLL THE VIDEO.
[ VIDEO PLAYING
]
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE. PLAY THE
MORNING PLAYLIST.
>>Google: OKAY. PLAYING
[ MUSIC ]
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE, PLAY MUSIC
IN ALL ROOMS.
[ MUSIC
]
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE, I'M
LISTENING.
>>Google: YOUR FLIGHT TO
PORTLAND IS DELAYED BY 30
MINUTES.
>>> CHANGE MY DINNER
RESERVATION TONIGHT FROM
SEVEN TO EIGHT.
>>Google: YOUR RESERVATION
AT ANDINA IS NOW CONFIRMED
FOR 8:00 P.M.
>>> HEY, GOOGLE, TEXT LOUISE,
FLIGHT DELAYED, DINNER MOVED
TO 8:00.
>>Google: OKAY. MESSAGE
SENT.
>>> GOOD MORNING.
>>> MORNING.
>>> HEY, GOOGLE, TURN THE
LIGHTS ON IN KEVIN'S ROOM.
>>> I THOUGHT YOU FINISHED
THAT ALREADY.
>>> UM, I FORGOT.
OKAY, GOOGLE, WHAT'S APPLES
IN SPANISH?
>>Google: MANZANAS.
>>> HEY, GOOGLE, HAS MY
PACKAGE SHIPPED?
>>Google: YES, IT'S ALREADY
SHIPPED.  IT WILL ARRIVE
TOMORROW.
>>> OH, IS THAT FOR ME?
>>> MAYBE.
>>> INTERESTING.
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE, HOW MANY
STARS ARE IN OUR GALAXY?
>>Google: WELL, THERE ARE
ABOUT 100 TO 400 BILLION
STAIRS ACCORDING TO
SPACE.COM.
>>> WHICH STAR IS THE
CLOSEST?
>>Google: ACCORDING TO NASA,
THE NEAREST STAR SYSTEM IS
ALPHA CENTAURI.
>>> CAN YOU XIAOMI WHAT IT
SHOW ME WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE ON THE TV?
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE, HOW IS
TRAFFIC FROM PEBBLE ROCK
SCHOOL TO THE AIRPORT?
>>Google: YOUR NORMAL ROUTE
HAS HEAVY TRAFFIC.  THERE'S A
FASTER ONE THAT WILL TAKE
ABOUT 35 MINUTES.  I'VE SENT
IT TO YOUR PHONE.
>>> OKAY. LET'S GO.
>>> DAD?
>>> HEY, GOOGLE, WHAT'S ON
THE CALENDAR TODAY?
>>Google: THE FIRST EVENT IS
SPACE DAY AT KEVIN'S SCHOOL.
IT STARTS AT 8:00 A.M.
>>> SPACE DAY. ARE YOU
READY, BUDDY?
>>> READY.
>>> LET'S GO.
[ VIDEO CONCLUDES.
>>> OKAY, GOOGLE. GOOD-BYE.
>>Google: GOOD-BYE.
[ VIDEO CONCLUDES ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
>>Mario Quieroz: WE'RE
REALLY, REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT'S AHEAD.  GOOGLE HOME
WILL BE AVAILABLE LATER THIS
YEAR.  IN THE MEANTIME, TO
STAY UP-TO-DATE WITH THE
LATEST NEWS, PLEASE SIGN UP
AT GOOGLE.COM/HOME.
WE WANTED TO SHARE THIS EARLY
PREVIEW AT I/O SO THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH PARTNERS IN A MORE
OPEN WAY TO DELIVER AWESOME
EXPERIENCES AT LAUNCH.  WE'LL
HAVE A LOT MORE TO SHARE SOON
WITH THE DEVELOPER COMMUNITY
ABOUT HOW TO BEGIN TO
INTEGRATE WITH THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT.
AND WITH THAT, LET ME ASK
SUNDAR BACK ON STAGE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
>>Sundar Pichai: THANK YOU,
MARIO.  IT'S REALLY EXCITING
TO SEE THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT
COME TO LIFE WITH GOOGLE HOME
AND TO HELP PEOPLE GET THINGS
DONE.  TO DO THIS WELL AS
MARIO MENTIONED, WE REALLY
NEED TO WORK WITH DEVELOPERS
AND THIRD PARTIES SO THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE THESE ACTIONS FOR
OUR USERS.
WE ALREADY DO THIS A LOT AT
GOOGLE TODAY.  USING GOOGLE
PRODUCTS, YOU CAN ALREADY
BOOK A MOVIE TICKET WITH
FANDANGO, GET A CAR WITH
UBER, LISTEN TO MUSIC ON
SPOTIFY, BOOK A RESTAURANT
WITH OPENTABLE, MAYBE RECORD
A RIDE WITH STRAVA, AND MANY,
MANY MORE SUCH USE CASES.
SO WE ARE THINKING ABOUT THIS
THOUGHTFULLY, AND WE'RE
WORKING ON A COMPREHENSIVE
WAY BY WHICH THIRD-PARTY
DEVELOPERS CAN INTERACT WITH
THE ASSISTANT, AND WE'LL BE
SHARING A LOT MORE IN THE
UPCOMING MONTHS.
I TALKED EARLIER THAT WE ARE
WORKING HARD AT CORE USE
CASES ON MOBILE.  ONE SUCH
IMPORTANT USE CASE IS PHOTOS.
LAST YEAR, THANKS TO THE
ADVANCES IN COMPUTER VISION,
WE APPROACHED PHOTOS WITH A
NEW PERSPECTIVE.  WE
ANNOUNCED GOOGLE PHOTO AT
GOOGLE I/O LAST YEAR WITH THE
GOAL TO HELP USERS FIND AND
ORGANIZE THEIR PHOTOS AND
VIDEOS, KEEP THEM SAFE, AND
SHARE THEM EFFORTLESSLY WITH
THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS ON
ANY DEVICE.
WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS
ADOPTION WITH GOOGLE PHOTOS,
AND JUST IN THE PAST YEAR, WE
HAVE SEEN TREMENDOUS
ADOPTION, AND TODAY WE ARE AT
OVER 200 MILLION MONTHLY
ACTIVE USERS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OUR COMPUTER VISION SYSTEMS
HAVE AUTOMATICALLY APPLIED
OVER 2 TRILLION LABELS.  THIS
IS WHAT ALLOWS US, WHEN YOU
SEARCH FOR POMERANIAN, TO
FIND THE RIGHT PICTURE.  AND
BY THE WAY, OVER 24 BILLION
OF THOSE LABELS ARE FOR
SELFIES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE EVEN HAVE POMERANIAN
SELFIES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOGLE PHOTOS SHOWS WHAT'S
POSSIBLE WHEN YOU APPROACH AN
EXISTING AREA FROM A NEW
PERSPECTIVE.
ANOTHER CORE USE CASE ON
USERS' PHONES IS
COMMUNICATIONS.  IT'S AN
EXCITING AREA, AND THERE IS A
LOT OF INNOVATION.  BUT GIVEN
OUR ADVANCEMENTS IN MACHINE
LEARNING, WE WANTED TO
APPROACH THIS CORE USE CASE
WITH A NEW PERSPECTIVE.  ERIK
KAY IS GOING TO JOIN TO TALK
TO YOU MORE ABOUT IT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
>>Erik Kay: ] THANKS, SUNDAR.
YOU KNOW, COMMUNICATIONS IS
ALL ABOUT SHARING LIFE'S
MOMENTS.  THAT GREAT
RESTAURANT I FOUND, THE
WINNING SHOT IN OVERTIME, MY
DAUGHTER'S RECITAL.  TODAY I
CAN SHARE MOMENTS LIKE THESE
THE SECOND THEY HAPPEN, JUST
BY PULLING OUT MY PHONE AND
SENDING A MESSAGE.
COMMUNICATIONS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR LIVES,
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT FOCUS
FOR GOOGLE AS WELL.  WHAT
MAKES ME PERSONALLY EXCITED
ABOUT COMMUNICATIONS IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR INNOVATION WHEN
YOU COMBINE THE POWER OF
MOBILE WITH ADVANCEMENTS IN
MACHINE LEARNING.
SO TODAY WE'RE GIVING YOU A
LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE BEEN UP TO
WITH TWO NEW COMMUNICATION
APPS THAT SHOW WHAT'S
POSSIBLE WHEN WE BRING GOOGLE
TECHNOLOGY TO THIS ESSENTIAL
HUMAN ACTIVITY.
THE FIRST IS A NEW MESSAGING
APP CALLED ALLO.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU.
ALLO IS A SMART MESSAGING
APP.  IT LEARNS OVER TIME TO
MAKE CONVERSATIONS EASIER,
MORE EXPRESSIVE, AND MORE
PRODUCTIVE BY BRINGING ALL
THE RICHNESS OF GOOGLE RIGHT
INTO YOUR CHAT.  ALLO IS
BASED ON YOUR PHONE NUMBER SO
YOU CAN EASILY GET IN TOUCH
WITH ANYONE IN YOUR PHONE
BOOK.
THIS MORNING, WE'RE GOING TO
WALK YOU THROUGH THREE AREAS
THAT MAKE ALLO REALLY
SPECIAL.  FIRST ARE SOME WAYS
TO EXPRESS YOURSELF AND KEEP
THE CONVERSATION GOING.
THEN, WE'LL TALK ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS TO HAVE THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT BUILT RIGHT INTO
YOUR MESSAGING APP.  AND,
FINALLY, WE'LL TELL YOU HOW
ALLO KEEPS YOUR CONVERSATIONS
PRIVATE AND SECURE.  SO LET'S
GET STARTED.
ON THE STAGE WITH ME TO HELP
DEMO IS AMIT.  HE LEADS
PRODUCT MANAGEMENT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND ON THE SCREEN BEHIND ME
YOU CAN SEE AMIT'S IN A
CHAT -- IN A CONVERSATION
WITH HIS FRIEND JOY.  SO WE
DESIGNED ALLO TO HELP YOU
EXPRESS YOURSELF AND KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING.  SO, OF
COURSE, THERE'S A GREAT
SELECTION OF STICKERS WHICH
WE'VE SOURCED FROM
INDEPENDENT ARTISTS AND
CONTENT PRODUCERS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD.  BUT EXPRESSION IS
MORE THAN JUST EMOJIS AND
STICKERS.  SO WE'VE ADDED
MORE FEATURES THAT HELP YOU
SAY WHAT YOU MEAN.  FIRST,
LET'S LOOK AT WHISPER SHOUT.
WE WANTED TO GIVE YOU A WAY
TO ADD MORE EMOTION TO YOUR
WORDS.  SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO
GET YOUR POINT ACROSS BIG  AND
BOLD.  OTHER TIMES YOU
%%%CHUCKSTART WANT
TO SAY THINGS A BIT MORE
SOFTLY.
WHISPER SHOUT LET'S YOU
EXPREPS HOW
EXPRESS HOW YOU REALLY FEEL
BY MAKING YOUR REPLIES VERY
BIG OR VERY SMALL.  AMIT, CAN
YOU SHOW EVERYONE HOW THAT
WORKS?
SO AMIT HAS TYPED "YAY" AND
THRONE A SMILEY
THROWN A SMILEY FACE IN
THERE.  RATHER THAN HITTING
THE TAP BUTTON, HE SLIDES THE
BUTTON DOWN TO WHISPER AND UP
TO SHOUT.  DOWN TO WHISPER
AND UP AGAIN TO SHOUT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I THINK IT'S PRETTY COOL,
TOO.  NO MORE YELLING IN ALL
CAPS TO GET YOUR POINT
ACROSS.
IT'S ALSO FUN TO ADD EMOTION
TO YOUR PHOTOS.  AND INK
LET'S YOU GET CREATIVE WITH
THE PHOTOS YOU SEND.  AMIT'S
PICKED A PHOTO OF HIS
ADORABLE BABY GIRL AND WROTE
AHOY ON THE LITTLE SAILOR.
POSTED IT.  IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
I USE INK ALL THE TIME.  IT'S
REALLY FUN.  ANOTHER WAY ALLO
HELPS YOU EXPRESS YOURSELF IS
BY LETTING YOU TYPE LESS, A
LOT LESS.  WE'VE TAKEN A PAGE
FROM THE INBOX PLAYBOOK AND
BUILT SMART REPLY RIGHT INTO
YOUR CHAT CONVERSATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THIS IS ESPECIALLY POWERFUL
IN MESSAGING WHEN YOU'RE ON
THE GO.  SO NOW YOU CAN KEEP
YOUR CONVERSATIONS GOING WITH
JUST A QUICK TAP.  SO YOU CAN
SEE WHEN JOY ASKS:  DINNER
LATER?  THAT AMIT HAS OFFERED
TWO SMART REPLY SUGGESTIONS:
I'M BUSY AND I'M IN!  OKAY.
I PROMISE I WON'T ACT OUT ANY
MORE EMOJIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO ALLO USES MACHINE LEARNING
TO SUGGEST REPLIES ON THE
FLY, ANTICIPATING WHAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO SAY NEXT.  NOW,
THESE AREN'T JUST CANNED
REPLIES.  ALLO LEARNS OVER
TIME AND WILL SUGGEST
RESPONSES BASED ON HOW YOU
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOURSELF.
THE MORE YOU USE ALLO THE
BETTER THE SUGGESTIONS WILL
BECOME.  SO THE SUGGESTIONS
YOU SEE ARE UNIQUE TO YOU.
YOU CAN SAY THE THINGS YOU
WANT WITHOUT HAVING TO TYPE A
SINGLE WORD.  AND SINCE
MESSAGING ISN'T JUST ABOUT
TEXT, SMART REPLIES CONTAIN
STICKERS AND EMOJIS, TOO,
BECAUSE AS THEY SAY, AN
EMOJI'S WORTH A THOUSAND
WORDS.  DO THEY SAY THAT?
[ LAUGHTER
]
NOW I WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING REALLY COOL.  ALLO
EVEN OFFERS SMART REPLIES
WHEN PEOPLE SEND PHOTOS TO
YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THIS WORKS BECAUSE IN
ADDITION TO UNDERSTANDING
TEXT, ALLO BUILDS ON GOOGLE'S
COMPUTER VISION CAPABILITIES
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONTENT AND THE CONTEXT OF
IMAGES.  IN THIS CASE, ALLO
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE PICTURE
WAS OF A DOG, THAT IT WAS A
CUTE DOG, AND EVEN THE BREED
OF THE DOG.  IN OUR INTERNAL
TESTING, WE FOUND THAT ALLO
IS 90% ACCURATE IN
DETERMINING WHETHER A DOG
DESERVES THE "CUTE DOG"
RESPONSE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO LET'S TRY SOMETHING EVEN
HARDER.  WHEN JOY SENDS A
PHOTO OF PASTA, WE'RE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE PRECISE DETAILS
OF THE IMAGE AND CREATE SMART
REPLIES MENTION MENTIONING BOTH
LINGUINI AND THE CLAMS.
WHAT'S REALLY COOL HERE IS WE
DON'T JUST IDENTIFY WHAT'S IN
THE IMAGE.  SMART REPLY
ACTUALLY CREATES A
CONVERSATIONAL RESPONSE,
SOMETHING LIKE "YUMMY," THE
KIND OF THING YOU WOULD
ACTUALLY SAY IN RESPONSE TO A
PHOTO OF FOOD.  THIS IS ONLY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE'VE
MARRIED OUR STRENGTHS IN
COMPUTER VISION AND NATURAL
LANGUAGE PROCESSING.  AND IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THERE'S A
LOT OF COMPLEX TECHNOLOGY AT
WORK HERE JUST TO HELP YOU
SAY SOMETHING AS FUN -- AS
SIMPLE AND NATURAL AS "I LOVE
LINGUINI."  SO, THAT'S A
LITTLE HOW ALLO HELPS YOU
EXPRESS YOURSELF AND KEEP
YOUR CONVERSATIONS GOING.
THE INTELLIGENCE BEHIND SMART
REPLY ALSO GIVES YOU A TASTE
AT HOW ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY
CAN MAKE YOUR MESSAGE
EXPERIENCE SIMPLER AND MORE
PRODUCTIVE.  THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT BUILT RIGHT INTO
ALLO TAKES IT EVEN FARTHER,
SO I'M PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
ONE OF OUR LEADS, REBECCA, TO
TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THE
ASSISTANT IN ALLO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Rebecca Michael: THANKS,
ERIK.  AS YOU HEARD EARLIER,
THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT IS AN OP
GOING DIALOG BETWEEN YOU AND
GOOGLE THAT HELPS YOU GET
THINGS DONE IN YOUR WORLD.
IT'S ALSO DESIGNED AS AN
AMBIENT EXPERIENCE.  IT'S
THERE FOR YOU WHENEVER YOU
NEED IT.  AND IN MESSAGING
THAT REALLY MEANS BRINGING
THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT RIGHT
INTO YOUR CONVERSATION WITH
FRIENDS.  SO I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU HOW THE ASSISTANT
CAN HELP IN AMIT'S AND JOY'S
CONVERSATION.  SO THEY'RE
PLANNING A DINNER AND JOY NOW
SAYS SHE WOULD LIKE ITALIAN
FOOD.  THE ASSISTANT
INTELLIGENTLY RECOGNIZES THAT
THEY COULD USE SOME TIPS FOR
ITALIAN RESTAURANTS NEAR AND
YOU CAN SEE IT'S PROACTIVE
SUGGESTIONS AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE SCREEN.  TAPPING THIS
BRINGS UP RESTAURANT CARDS
THAT EVERYONE IN THE CHAT CAN
SEE.
THESE ARE POWERED GUY
GOOGLE'S KNOWLEDGE GRAPH
WHICH MEANS THAT ALLO CAN
HELP WITH ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION IN THE REAL WORLD
WORLD.  SO THERE'S SOME BACK
AND FORTH ABOUT WHICH
RESTAURANT TO GO TO.  IT
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE LEANING
TOWARDS CUCINA AT 7:00.  SO
AMIT TAPS ON THE RESTAURANT
CARD TO BRING UP MORE
DETAILS.  LOOKS GOOD.  SERVES
PASTA WHICH WE KNOW JOY
FANCIED.  SO AMIT CAN NOW GO
AHEAD AND MAKE A RESERVATION
RIGHT THERE THROUGH OPEN
TABLE.  THE ASSISTANT PROMPTS
HIM TO CONFIRM THE NUMBER OF
DINERS AND WHAT TIME THEY
WANT TO EAT.  AND NOW THEY'RE
BOOKED AND READY TO GO.
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE --
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IS
COMPLETELY NEW.  IN THE PAST,
AMIT WOULD HAVE HAD TO LEAVE
THE CHAT TO DO A GOOGLE
SEARCH, RETURN WITH SOME
RESTAURANT OPTIONS, SWITCH
BACK AGAIN TO SHARE THE
OPTIONS, GO OUT AGAIN TO MAKE
THE RESERVATION AT OPEN TABLE
AND THEN COME BACK IN TO
SHARE THE DETAILS WITH THE
REST OF THE GROUP.  IN ALLO,
AMIT AND JOY CAN CHOOSE AND
RESERVE A RESTAURANT RIGHT
THERE IN THE CHAT AND IN A
NATURAL AND SEAMLESS WAY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO OPEN TABLE WILL BE JUST
ONE OF THE MANY PARTNERS THAT
WILL BE PART OF THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT ECOSYSTEM, AND WE
CAN'T WAIT TO SHARE MORE SOON
WITH THE DEVELOPER COMMUNITY
ABOUT HOW TO GET STARTED.
[ APPLAUSE ]
COOL.  SO WE SAW SOME
PROACTIVE SUGGESTIONS FROM
GOOGLE THERE.  YOU CAN ALSO
CALL ON THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT
DIRECTLY AT ANY TIME JUST BY
TYPING  @GOOGLE AS AMIT'S
DOING NOW.
AND HE'S GOING TO ASK FOR
FUNNY CAT PICS.  REALLY,
AMIT?  OKAY.  COOL.  SO
GOOGLE OBLIGES, OF COURSE,
WITH A LOVELY LINEUP OF CATS
FROM GOOGLE IMAGE SEARCH.
WOW, THAT CHIN.
OKAY.  SO YOU JUST SAW HOW
THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT CAN BE
REALLY HELPFUL IN GROUPS.
YOU CAN ALSO HAVE A ONE ON
ONE CHAT WITH GOOGLE.  WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW IS AMIT'S
CONTACT LIST AND GOOGLE'S
APPEARING AT THE TOP THERE.
SO LET'S JUMP IN AND HAVE A
CHAT.  JUST LIKE WITH ANY
OTHER CONVERSATION, THIS ONE
PICKS UP RIGHT WHERE YOU LEFT
OFF AND THE ASSISTANT WILL
REMEMBER THINGS LIKE YOUR
NAME AND EVEN TELL YOU HOW
IT'S FEELING.  LET'S TRY
SOMETHING MORE INTERESTING.
AMIT'S A BIG REAL MADRID FAN
AND HE WANTS TO NOW HOW THEY
GOT ON IN THEIR LAST MATCH.
WE WILL ASK THE ASSISTANT:
DID MY TEAM WIN?  IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY DID.  THEY WON
THEIR -- YEAH.  SO REAL
MADRID FANS OUT THERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
COOL.  AND SO THEY WON THEIR
LAST MATCH ON SATURDAY.
LET'S SEE WHEN THEY ARE
PLAYING
NEXT.  THAT'S PRETTY
COOL.  THEY ARE THROUGH THE
CHAMPION'S LEAGUE FINAL AT
THE END OF THE MONTH.  WE CAN
KEEP GOING LIKE THIS AND FIND
MORE NEWS ABOUT THE TEAM JUST
BY TAPPING ON THE SUGGESTIONS
THERE.  BUT LET'S GO AHEAD
AND TAP ON THEIR
ROSTER.
THERE WE GO.  WE HAVE A
CAROUSEL WITH ALL THEIR TOP
TALENT AND SHOULD WE CHECK
OUT EVERYONE'S FAVORITE?
MR. RONALDO.  LET'S SEE SOME
OF HIS BEST TRICKS.
SO AMIT ONLY HAS TO TYPE
"BEST TRICKS" AND THE
ASSISTANT UNDERSTANDS THE
CONTEXT AND THAT HE MEANS
RONALDO'S BEST TRICKS AND
RESPONDS WITH A YouTUBE
VIDEO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE WON'T PLAY THAT VIDEO NOW,
BUT IF WE DID TAP IT, IT
WOULD PLAY RIGHT THERE IN THE
CHAT.
SO, LET'S PLAY A GAME
INSTEAD.  AMIT'S ASKING
GOOGLE TO PLAY A GAME.  AND,
OKAY.  GOOGLE'S SUGGESTING
THE INC. EMOJI GAME.  THE WAY
THIS
WORKS GOOGLE PROVIDES A
STRING OF EMOJI AND YOU HAVE
TO GUESS THE FILM TITLE.  ARE
YOU READY?
>>> YES!
>>Rebecca Michael: YEAH?
LET'S PLAY!
OKAY.  SO LOOKS LIKE WE'VE
GOT A CROWN AND SOME RINGS.
ANY IDEAS?
>>> LORD OF THE RINGS.
>>Rebecca Michael: I HEAR
THE PRINCESS BRIDE OVER
THERE.  AMIT, ANY IDEAS?
LORD OF THE RINGS.  OH, IT
WAS TOO EASY.  OKAY.  WE
COULD KEEP GOING BUT I THINK
YOU GOT THE IDEA.  SO THAT
WAS OBVIOUSLY --
[ LAUGHTER ]
SHOULD WE KEEP GOING?  NO.
ANY IDEAS?
THEY'RE GOOD.
OKAY.  SO THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
SUPER SIM MEL GAME AND
SIMPLE GAME AND THERE'S
A BUNCH MORE YOU CAN PLAY IN
ALLO.  WE REALLY THINK THE
BEST GAMES WILL COME FROM THE
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY.
SO --
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO THAT WAS THE ASSISTANT IN
ALLO. ALLOWING YOU TO HARNESS
ALL OF THE RICHNESS AND
KNOWLEDGE FROM GOOGLE FROM
SEARCH, YouTUBE'S, MAPS,
PHOTOS AS WELL AS MANY OF OUR
PARTNERS TO HAVE FUN AND GET
THINGS DONE.  AS YOU SAW, THE
INTERFACE IS INHERENTLY
PERSONAL AND CONVERSATIONAL
AND THE SMART SUGGESTIONS
CHIP HELP TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION FLOWING.  MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE FIRST
TIME, YOU CAN USE GOOGLE IN
YOUR CHATS WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
AND WITH THAT, I'LL HAND IT
BACK TO ERIK.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Erik Kay: THANKS, REBECCA.
AND THANKS, AMIT.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES THAT GOOGLE
ASSISTANT BRINGS TO
MESSAGING.
NOW LET'S TALK A BIT ABOUT
PRIVACY AND SECURITY.  WE
REALIZE THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WANT TO BE INCOGNITO.  OF
COURSE, THIS APPLIES TO CHAT
AS WELL.  SO, FOLLOWING IN
THE FOOTSTEPS OF CHROME,
WE'VE CREATED AN INCOGNITO
MODE FOR ALLO.  WHILE ALL
MESSAGES IN ALLO ARE
ENCRYPTED, CHATS IN INCOGNITO
MODE ARE END-TO-END
ENCRYPTED.  INCOGNITO CHATS
HAVE DISCEET NOTIFICATIONS
BEHINDING THE SENDERS AND
SHOULDER SURFERS AND PRYING
EYES.  INCOGNITO ALSO OFFERS
MESSAGE EXPIRATION SO YOU'RE
IN CONTROL OF HOW LONG YOUR
PRIVATE MESSAGES STICK
AROUND.  AND SIMILAR TO WHEN
YOU CLOSE AN INCOGNITO WINDOW
IN CHROME, WHEN YOU DELETE AN
INCOGNITO CONVERSATION IN
ALLO, IT'S GONE FOREVER AND
NO ONE CAN SEE IT AGAIN ON
YOUR DEVICE.  WITH INCOGNITO
MODE, ALLO GIVES PIEWFERS
USERS
ADDITIONAL CONTROLS OVER
THEIR PRIVACY AND SECURITY
AND WE ANTICIPATE ADDING EVEN
MORE SECURITY FEATURES TO IT
OVER TIME.
SO THAT'S ALLO.  ALLO IS
FAST, SMART, AND SECURE AND
IT LET'S YOU EXPRESS YOURSELF
IN FUN NEW WAYS.  AND ALLO
WILL BE THE FIRST HOME FOR
THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT AS IT
STARTS TO TAKE SHAPE,
BRINGING THE RICHNESS OF
GOOGLE RIGHT INTO YOUR CHATS.
NOW, ALLO IS ALL ABOUT
MESSAGING BUT LET ME TALK TO
YOU A MINUTE ABOUT VIDEO
CALLING.  JUST AS TECHNOLOGY
HAS HELPED CONNECT PEOPLE
THROUGH MESSAGING, VIDEO
CALLING HAS BROUGHT FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS TOGETHER FROM
AROUND THE WORLD.  IT CAN BE
A MAGICAL EXPERIENCE, SO WHY
DON'T WE PICK UP THE PHONE
AND DO IT MORE OFTEN?  WELL,
MAYBE THE OTHER PERSON HAS A
DIFFERENT KIND OF PHONE.
MAYBE THE CONNECTION IS A
LITTLE SPOTTY.  AND EVEN WHEN
IT DOES WORK, GETTING A CALL
CAN OFTEN FEEL INTRUSIVE
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT QUITE SURE
WHY THE OTHER PERSON'S
CALLING.
THAT'S WHY WE CHALLENGED
OURSELVES TO DESIGN A VIDEO
CALLING EXPERIENCE THAT WOULD
FEEL MAGICAL EVERY TIME.  SO,
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
DUO., A SIMPLE ONE-TO-ONE
CALLING APP FOR EVERYONE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DUO IS THE VIDEO COMPANION TO
ALLO.  IT'S FAST AND PERFORMS
WELL EVEN ON SLOW NETWORKS.
IT'S END-TO-END ENCRYPTED.
IT'S BASED ON YOUR PHONE
NUMBER ALLOWING YOU TO EASILY
GET IN TOUCH WITH THE PEOPLE
YOU CARE ABOUT AND IT WORKS
ON BOTH ANDROID AND iOS.
BUT HERE'S A FEATURE THAT
MAKES ALLO REALLY SPECIAL.
WE CALL IT KNOCK KNOCK.
KNOCK KNOCK SHOWS YOU A LIVE
VIDEO STREAM OF THE CALLER
BEFORE YOU'VE EVEN PICKED UP.
NOT ONLY CAN YOU SEE WHO'S
CALLING BUT WHAT THEY'RE UP
TO AND WHY THEY'RE CALLING, A
SMILE, A BEACH, A NEWBORN
BABY CAN ALL DRAW YOU INTO
THE MOMENT, MAKING CALLS FEEL
SPONTANEOUS AND NATURAL.
AND ONCE YOU PICK UP, DUO
PUTS YOU RIGHT INTO THE CALL
SEAMLESSLY TRANSITIONING FROM
THE LIVE PREVIEW TO THE LIVE
CALL.  KNOCK KNOCK TOTALLY
CHANGES WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
RECEIVE A VIDEO CALL.  SO
LET'S TAKE A
LOOK.
AND ALMOST RIGHT ON CUE, I'M
GETTING A CALL FROM MY
DAUGHTER AVA.
I USE EYE HAVE A AVA FOR ALL MY
DEMOS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO AS YOU CAN SEE, AND ELENA
APPARENTLY, TOO, IS POPPING
IN THERE, I HAVEN'T EVEN
PICKED UP YET BUT AVA IS
RIGHT THERE SMILING AND
MAKING FUNNY FACES.  I CAN
TELL SHE IS REALLY EAGER TO
TALK.  SO LET'S ANSWER IT.
>>> HI, DAD.
>>Erik Kay: HI, AVA, HI,
ELENA.
>>> ARE YOU DONE WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION YET?
>>Erik Kay: ALMOST. I'LL BE
DONE SOON.  WITH YOU WAVE TO
EVERYBODY?
>>> HI, EVERYBODY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ERIK KAY K >>Erik Kay: I'LL
TALK TO YOU
SOON.
>>> BYE, DAD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>Erik Kay: OOPS.
SO YOU JUST SAW HOW KNOCK
KNOCK DREW US INTO THE
CONVERSATION WITH AVA AND
ELENA BEFORE WE EVEN PICKED
IT UP AND HOW FAST AND SMOOTH
IT WAS.  NOW, KNOCK KNOCK
ONLY WORKS WHEN THE VIDEO IS
INSTANT.  THERE CAN'T BE A
GAP BETWEEN THE PHONE RINGING
AND THE VIDEO APPEARING.
THIS IS A REALLY HARD TEXAS
TECHNICAL PROBLEM BUT WE'RE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO TACKLE
IT.  DUO WAS BUILT BY THE
TEAM THAT WAS CREATED WEBRTC
THE OPEN
SOURCE PLATFORM THAT NOW
POWERS MUCH OF TODAY'S MOBILE
VIDEO COMMUNICATION.  WE KNOW
THEY TECHNOLOGY LIKE NO ONE
ELSE.  WE USED A NEW PROTOCOL
CALLED QUIC THAT ALLOWS DUO
TO ESTABLISH AN ENCRYPTED
CONNECTION IN A SINGLE ROUND
TRIP.  WE OBSESSED OVER EVERY
LAST DETAIL OF VIDEO
TRANSMISSION, HAND TUNING AND
OPTIMIZING CODECS, BANDWIDTH
PROBING, ENCRYPTION AND MORE.
THE RESULT IS THE UNIQUE FEEL
OF KNOCK KNOCK.  YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE IN AN
INSTANT.
SO THE OTHER THING THAT
REALLY SETS DUO APART IS HOW
RELIABLE IT MAKES VIDEO
CALLING.  DUO WORKS WHEREVER
YOU ARE, WHETHER IT'S
NEW YORK OR NEW DELHI,
BUENOS AIRES OR BUTTE, AT
HOME OR ON THE ROAD.  DUO
PROACTIVELY MONITORS NETWORK
QUALITY MULTIPLE TIMES PER
SECOND, ALLOWING IT TO
DEGRADE GRACEFULLY WHEN
BANDWIDTH IS LIMITED AND TO
SEAMLESSLY SWITCH BETWEEN
WiFi AND CELLAR.  AND, OF
COURSE, THIS ALL HAPPENS
AUTOMATICALLY BEHIND THE
SCENES SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT IT.
ALL THIS TECHNOLOGY COMBINES
WITH A SMOOTH INTERFACE THAT
FADES AWAY AN I LOUING YOU TO
FOCUS ON EACH OTHER IN
BEAUTIFUL HD VIDEO AND AUDIO.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES DUO A
VIDEO CALLING EXPERIENCE THAT
FEELS UNLIKE ANYTHING YOU'VE
USED BEFORE.  NOW, I'D LIKE
TO SHOW YOU A SHORT VIDEO
THAT SHOWS HOW DUO BRINGS
MAGIC BACK TO VIDEO CALLING.
[ VIDEO PLAYING. ]
>>> YOU READY? ONE, TWO,
THREE!
>>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
>>> READY? THREE!
>>> MEET BABY ALEX.
>>> READY? ONE, TWO, THREE!
>>> NO WAY!
>>> THAT'S TOO
CUTE.
>>> WHERE ARE YOU?
>>> HOLD ON, I GOT TO GET
THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> THREE.
(SCREAMING).
[ VIDEO CONCLUDES ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Erik Kay: YOU CAN REALLY
SEE HOW FUN AND SPONTANEOUS
VIDEO CALLS BECOME WITH DUO.
WE'RE INCREDIBLY EXCITED TO
BE CONNECTING PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE WORLD WITH THESE TWO NEW
APPS:  ALLO, A SMART
MESSAGING APP WITH EXPRESSION
AND THE POWER OF THE GOOGLE
ASSISTANT.  AND DUO, A SIMPLE
VIDEO APP WITH THE
SPONTANEITY OF KNOCK KNOCK.
BOTH ALLO AND DUO WILL BE
AVAILABLE THIS SUMMER ON
ANDROID AND iOS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW TO TALK TO YOU A BIT
ABOUT ANDROID, I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE TO THE STAGE OUR
RESIDENT ROCK STAR DAVE BURKE
BURKE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Dave Burke: THANKS, ERIC.
HEY, I'M DAVE.  IT'S AMAZING
TO BE HERE AT GOOGLE I/O 2016
AT THE SHORELINE
AMPHITHEATRE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT.  WHAT A GREAT
VENUE.  I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE THE VERY CLOSEST I GET
TO MY CHILDHOOD DREAM OF
BEING A ROCK STAR ON THE
STAGE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG ABOUT
NERDS BEING ALLOWED ON A ROCK
STAR STAGE LIKE THIS.
ANYWAY, SO FAR WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE SCALE OF MOBILE AND
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT EVOLVING
OUR PRODUCTS TO BE SMARTER
AND MORE ASSISTIVE THROUGH
MACHINE LEARNING AND AI AND A
KEY DRIVER OF THIS SCALE IS
ANDROID.  AS YOU'VE HEARD,
THIS YEAR MARKS THE TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF OUR FIRST
DEVELOPER CONFERENCE.  IT'S
ALSO BEEN 10 YEARS SINCE WE
STARTED WORKING ON ANDROID.
SO HOW ARE WE DOING?
WELL, ANDROID IS THE MOST
POPULAR OS IN THE WORLD.
MORE THAN 600 ANDROID
SMARTPHONES HAVE LAUNCHED IN
THE LAST YEAR ALONE.
EVERYTHING FROM DISNEY
PRINCESS PHONES TO METAL
UNIBODY DEVICES TRICKED OUT
IN TITANIUM.  THERE'S A PHONE
FOR EVERYONE.
AND AS ANDROID CONTINUES TO
EXPAND INTO NEW SCREENS LIKE
ON THE WRIST AND IN THE CAR
AND ON TVs AND CONNECTED
DEVICES, THERE'S INCREASED
OPPORTUNITY FOR DEVELOPERS TO
REACH USERS WHETHER THEY'RE
AT HOME OR ON THE GO.
ANDROID WEAR.  THERE ARE NOW
12 PARTNER BRANDS WITH ICONIC
WATCH MAKERS LIKE TAG HEUER
AND DESIGNERS LIKE MICHAEL
KORS.
ANDROID TV.  THERE ARE NOW
MILLIONS OF NEW ANDROID TV
DEVICES, GROWING RAPIDLY,
WITH MEDIA CONTENT AND GAMES
FROM THE BIGGEST NAMES IN THE
INDUSTRY.
ANDROID AUTO.  MORE THAN
100 CAR MODELS AND STEREOS
HAVE LAUNCHED WITH ANOTHER
HUNDRED ON THEIR WAY BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
AND, OF COURSE, GOOGLE PLAY.
THERE WERE 65 BILLION
INSTALLS IN THE LAST YEAR
ALONE AND I'M JUST IN
CONSTANT AWE OF ALL THE
AMAZING APPS AND SERVICES
THAT YOU'RE CREATING THAT'S
FUELING THIS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
NEW IN THE PLATFORM.  WITH
THE N RELEASE, WE WANTED TO
ACHIEVE A NEW LEVEL OF
PRODUCT EXCELLENCE SO WE SET
ABOUT REDESIGNING AND
REWRITING MANY FUNDAMENTAL
ASPECTS OF HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS.
NOW, A LOT OF THE FEATURES IN
N WERE INSPIRED BY USERS.
HOW THEY USE THEIR PHONES,
WHAT THEY'VE TOLD US, AND HOW
WE THINK WE CAN MAKE THEIR
DAY-TO-DAY EXPERIENCE BETTER
AND MORE USEFUL.
THIS YEAR WE DECIDED TO DO
SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BY RELEASING EARLY DEVELOPER
PREVIEWS OF THE N RELEASE
BEFORE GOOGLE I/O.
WE WANT TO SHARE OUR WORK IN
PROGRESS WITH YOU AS WE BUILD
IT SO WE HAVE MORE TIME FOR
YOUR FEEDBACK.
ALSO, GETTING THE PLATFORM
OUT EARLIER MEANS THERE'S
MORE TIME FOR APP DEVELOPERS
AND DEVICE MAKERS TO BE READY
FOR THE RELEASE LATER THIS
YEAR.
THE RESPONSE TO THE N
DEVELOPER PREVIEW HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMING.  MANY OF YOU
ARE ALREADY DEVELOPING ON THE
N PREVIEW RELEASE ON A DAILY
BASIS AND IT'S JUST HUMBLING
TO BE PART OF A PROJECT OF
THIS SCALE.  SO THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF THE FEEDBACK SO FAR.
NOW, OFTEN ONE OF THE HARDEST
PARTS OF CREATING AN ANDROID
RELEASE IS COMING UP WITH THE
NAME.  AND I HAVE NO IDEA
WHY, BUT THIS YEAR THE N
DESSERT NAME IS PROVING
TRICKIER THAN ALL OF THE
OTHERS, SO FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, WE'RE GOING TO BE
INVITING THE WORLD TO SUBMIT
THEIR IDEAS TO
WWW.ANDROID.COM/N.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND WE'RE FORWARD TO YOUR
INPUT BUT PLEASE DON'T CALL
IT NAMEYMcNAMEFACE.  I
SHOULD ADD THAT WE ALL
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO PICK THE
WINNER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT.  IN THE MEANTIME,
LET'S JUMP STRAIGHT IN AND
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
BIGGEST CHANGES IN N AROUND
PERFORMANCE, SECURITY, AND
PRODUCTIVITY.
LET'S START WITH PERFORMANCE.
WE'VE IMPROVED PERFORMANCE IN
N IN TWO KEY AREAS:  GRAPHICS
AND RUNTIME.
IN RECENT ANDROID RELEASES,
WE EXTENDED THE OpenGL
STANDARD TO BRING ADVANCED
GRAPHICS CAPABILITIES,
USUALLY FOUND ON DESKTOP AND
GAME CONSOLES, TO MOBILE.
WITH N, WE'RE MAKING OUR
BIGGEST LEAP FORWARD WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF VULKAN.
VULKAN IS A MODERN 3D
GRAPHICS API DESIGNED TO GIVE
GAME DEVELOPERS DIRECT
CONTROL OF THE GPU TO PRODUCE
INCREDIBLE GRAPHICS AND
COMPUTE PERFORMANCE.
AND WE MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY ON VULKAN SO YOU CAN
USE THE SAME PAYS AND
GRAPHICS ASSETS AND SHADERS
ON THE DESKTOP AS WELL AS
MOBILE.
BECAUSE VULKAN HAS A LOWER
CPU OVERHEAD THAN OpenGL,
GAME DEVELOPERS ARE ABLE TO
SQUEEZE IN MORE EFFECTS PER
FRAME WHILE STILL MAINTAINING
A HIGH FRAME RATE.  LET'S
TAKE A LOOK AT A NEXUS 6P
RUNNING A KNEW VERSION OF THE
NEED FOR SPEED GAME BY
ELECTRONIC ARTS AND THERE ARE
A BUNCH OF REALLY NICE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS VERSION
THANKS TO VULKAN.  YOU'LL
NOTICE THE BEAUTIFUL GRAPHICS
IN REFLEXION ON THE CAR.
ALSO CHECK OUT THE REALISTIC
MOTION BLUR EFFECT WHICH IS
COMPUTED FOR EVERY OBJECT AT
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
AND THERE'S A REALLY NICE
WATER SURFACE EFFECT ON THE
ROAD.  AND THE SHADERS FOR
THESE ARE PRE-COMPILED AHEAD
OF TIME AND CAN NOW RUN
ANYWHERE.
SO THAT'S GRAPHICS
PERFORMANCE.
WE'VE ALSO SPENT A LOT OF
EFFORT WORKING ON IMPROVING
THE ANDROID RUNTIME.
FIRST, WE'VE MADE MAJOR
OPTIMIZATIONS TO OUR
COMPILER.  THE COMPILER IN N
PERFORMS ANYTHING FROM 30 TO
600% FASTER ON MAJOR CPU
BENCHMARKS LIKE DHRYSTONE.
SECOND, WE'VE ADDED A NEW
JUST-IN-TIME OR LEGITIMATE
COMPILE HE COMPILER AND
LEGITIMATE COMPILATION MEANS
THAT APP INSTALLS ARE FASTER.
75% FASTER IN N.  SO NOW
USERS CAN GET UP AND RUNNING
MUCH MORE QUICKLY ON YOUR
APPS.  AND ALSO BECAUSE
LEGITIMATE IS MORE SELECTIVE
ABOUT WHICH METHODS IT
COMPILES, BY A FULL 50%.
NOW, UNLIKE CONVENTIONAL
LEGITIMATE SYSTEMS, THE
ANDROID RUNTIME USES PROFILE
GUIDE THE OPTIMIZATION TO
WRITE COMPILED CODE TO FLASH
FOR THE NEXT TIME YOU RUN THE
APP, SO THIS IMPROVES
PERFORMANCE AND REDUCES
BATTERY CONSUMPTION.
IN SUMMARY, THE NEW
LEGITIMATE COMPILER IMPROVES
SOFTWARE PERFORMANCE, MAKES
INSTALLS FASTER, AND REDUCES
THE AMOUNT OF STORAGE YOU
NEED FOR APPS ON YOUR DEVICE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ANOTHER BIG
AREA OF FOCUS FOR US.
SECURITY.
WE DESIGNED ANDROID FROM THE
BEGINNING WITH A MULTILAYERED
DEFENSE-IN-DEPTH SECURITY
ARCHITECTURE.
AND ANDROID EMPLOYS THE
LATEST CUTTING-EDGE SECURITY
TECHNOLOGIES.  THINGS LIKE
SELINUX, VERIFIED BOOT
INTEGRITY, AND FULL DISK
ENCRYPTION.
WITH N, WE'RE CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN OUR DEFENSES IN
THREE KEY WAYS.
FIRST, N INTRODUCES
FILE-BASED ENCRYPTION.  BY
ENCRYPTING AT THE FILE LEVEL
INSTEAD OF THE BLOCK LEVEL,
WE'RE ABLE TO BETTER ISOLATE
AND PROTECT INDIVIDUAL USERS
OF THE SYSTEM.
SECOND, WE LEARNED THE
IMPORTANCE LAST YEAR OF
HARDENING THE SECURITY OF THE
MEDIA FRAMEWORK.  ESPECIALLY
SINCE IT'S ACCESSING FILES
FROM ANYWHERE ON THE
INTERNET.
SO IN N, WE'VE SPLIT OUT KEY
SUBSYSTEMS INTO INDIVIDUAL
SELINUX PROTECTED PROCESSES.
THINGS LIKE CODECS AND FILE
EXTRACTORS.  BY IMPROVING THE
SECURITY OF THE MEDIA
FRAMEWORK, WE IMPROVE THE
SECURITY OF THE ENTIRE
DEVICE.
THIRD, AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY COOL, N
AUTOMATICALLY KEEPS YOUR
PHONE UP-TO-DATE WITH THE
LATEST VERSION OF THE SYSTEM
SOFTWARE WITHOUT YOU HAVING
TO DO ANYTHING.
LIKE CHROMEBOOKS, NEW ANDROID
DEVICES BUILT ON N HAVE TWO
SYSTEM UPDATE -- TWO SYSTEM
IMAGES.  SO WHEN AN UPDATE IS
AVAILABLE, YOUR PHONE WILL
AUTOMATICALLY DOWNLOAD THE
NEW SYSTEM IMAGE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
SO THE NEXT TIME YOU POWER UP
YOUR PHONE, IT WILL
SEAMLESSLY SWITCH INTO THE
NEW SOFTWARE IMAGE.
YOU'RE NO LONGER ASKED FOR
YOUR PASSWORD WHEN THE PHONE
POWERS UP, THANKS TO
FILE-BASED ENCRYPTION AND A
NEW FEATURE CALLED "DIRECT
BOOT."  AND THAT PESKY
"ANDROID IS UPGRADING
DIALOGUE" IS FINALLY GONE,
THANKS TO THE NEW LEGITIMATE
JIT
COMPILER.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IS ACTUALLY DELETING CODE, BY
THE WAY.  ALL RIGHT.  THIS
APPROACH TO SOFTWARE UPDATES
IS ONE OF THE MOST LOVED
FEATURES OF CHROMEBOOKS AND
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO BRING
IT TO MOBILE AS WELL.  SO
THAT'S SOME OF THE WAYS WE'RE
IMPROVING SECURITY MECHANISMS
IN THE PLATFORM BUT LET'S NOT
FORGET ABOUT ALL OF THE
SECURITY SERVICES THAT GOOGLE
PROVIDES TO KEEP ALL ANDROID
DEVICES SAFE.
IN FACT, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE SCALE OF ANDROID AND
GOOGLE PLAY AND THE NUMBER OF
DEVICES AND APPS OUT THERE,
WE'RE PROVIDING ONE OF THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE MOBILE
SECURITY SOLUTIONS IN THE
WORLD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT A FEW
EXAMPLES.
GOOGLE CHROME PROTECTS USERS
WHEN THEY'RE SURFING THE WEB
THROUGH A SYSTEM CALLED SAFE
BROWSING.  SAFE BROWSING
WARNS USERS AHEAD OF TIME
WHEN THEY'RE ABOUT TO GO TO A
SITE THAT WE KNOW CONTAINS NO
-- MALWARE OR IS KNOWN TO
BE DECEPTIVE.
TODAY, WE'RE PROTECTING OVER
1 BILLION MOBILE CHROME
USERS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW WE
PROTECT USERS IS THROUGH THE
GOOGLE PLAY STORE.  ALL
ANDROID APPS UNDERGO RIGOROUS
SECURITY TESTING BEFORE
APPEARING ON THE STORE.
WE REVIEW EVERY APP TO MAKE
SURE IT MEETS OUR POLICIES.
WE ALSO RUN AN APP SECURITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WITH
DEVELOPERS TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL SECURITY
VULNERABILITIES.  FOR
EXAMPLE, WE'VE WORKED WITH
KEY BANKING AND eCOMMERCE
APPLICATIONS TO SURE THEY'RE
USING HTTPS PROPERLY TO
PROTECT AGAINST
MAN-IN-THE-MIDDLE ATTACKS.
GOOGLE PLAY ITSELF IS BUILT
ON A STATE-OF-THE-ART
CLOUD-BASED INFRASTRUCTURE WE
CALL "SAFETYNET."
SAFETYNET -- WITH SAFETYNET
GOOGLE'S EXPERT SYSTEMS AND
MACHINE LEARNING MODELS
ANALYZE BILLIONS OF SIGNALS
EVERY DAY TO PREDICT BAD
BEHAVIOR.  IF AN APP STEPS
OUT OF LINE, GOOGLE PLAY WILL
BLOCK OR UNINSTALL THE APP,
NO MATTER WHERE IT WAS
INSTALLED FROM.
AND THE SCALE OF SAFETYNET IS
EXTRAORDINARY.  EVERY DAY, WE
-- WE TEST OVER A BILLION
DEVICES AND OVER 8 BILLION
INSTALLED APPS.  AND ALL OF
THIS HAPPENS UNDER THE HOOD
TO KEEP YOU SAFE AND SECURE,
NO MATTER WHAT VERSION OF
ANDROID YOU'RE ON.
LET'S MOVE ON.
A THIRD AREA OF FOCUS FOR US
IS OUR CONTINUED EFFORT TO
IMPROVE PRODUCTIVITY.  AND
WE'VE TAKEN A CLOSE LOOK AT
HOW PEOPLE MULTITASK ON
ANDROID, TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
WORKING FOR THEM AND WHERE WE
CAN IMPROVE.
AND WE'VE PARTICULARLY
FOCUSED ON THE RECENT APPS
SCREEN.  AND WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM OUR USER RESEARCH IS
THAT OVER 99% OF THE TIME,
PEOPLE ONLY SELECT AN APP
WITHIN THE LAST SEVEN.
SO WE DECIDED TO SIMPLIFY BY
AUTOMATICALLY REMOVING APPS
IN THE LIST THAT YOU HAVEN'T
USED IN A WHILE.
THIS THEN MAKES IT MUCH
EASIER TO FIND THE APP THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
ALSO, BASED ON POPULAR
DEMAND, WE'VE FINALLY ADDED A
"CLEAR ALL" BUTTON AT THE
TOP.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YEAH.  FEELS GOOD!
BUT MY ABSOLUTE FAVORITE
FEATURE IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CALL "QUICK SWITCH."  YOU CAN
NOW FLIP TO THE PREVIOUS APP
YOU WERE IN JUST BY
DOUBLE-TAPPING THE RECENTS
BUTTON FROM ANYWHERE.  YOU
CAN THINK OF IT LIKE A
SIMPLIFIED ALT-TAB.  AND IT'S
AMAZINGLY USEFUL IN SO MANY
SITUATIONS.  FOR EXAMPLE,
LET'S SAY I'M IN A PHONE CALL
AND I'M TRYING TO COORDINATE
AN EVENT.  I CAN FLIP OVER TO
THE CALENDAR APP I WAS JUST
IN BY DOUBLE-TAPPING THE
RECENTS BUTTON AT THE BOTTOM
RIGHT.  FROM THERE, I CAN
CHECK MY SCHEDULE AND THEN
FLIP BACK TO THE DIALER BY
DOUBLE-TAPPING THE RECENTS
BUTTON AGAIN.  IT'S PRETTY
COOL.
NOW, MANY OF YOU HAVE ALSO
ASKED FOR THE ABILITY TO
DISPLAY MORE THAN ONE APP AT
THE SAME TIME.  SO WE'VE
INVESTED A LOT OF EFFORT IN
REDESIGNING OUR WINDOW
MANAGEMENT FRAMEWORK IN N.
AND WE'RE INTRODUCING TWO
POWERFUL NEW WINDOWING MODES
IN THIS RELEASE:
SPLIT-SCREEN AND
PICTURE-IN-PICTURE.
SPLINT-SCREEN IS DESIGNED FOR
TABLETS AND PHONES AND IT'S
REALLY SIMPLE TO USE.
SO FOLKS LET'S SAY I'M
WATCHING A VIDEO ON YouTUBE
TO LEARN HOW TO MAKE THE BEST
NACHOS.  I CAN LONG-TAP ON
THE RECENTS BUTTON TO ENTER
MULTI-WINDOW AND FROM LAUNCH
SOMETHING LIKE GOOGLE KEEP,
FOR EXAMPLE.  NOW YOU CAN
UPDATE MY SHOPPING LIST FOR
INGREDIENTS WHILE I'M
WATCHING THE VIDEO.
THE SECOND MODE,
PICTURE-IN-PICTURE, IS
DESIGNED FOR ANDROID TV AND
IT'S A GREAT WAY TO LET YOU
KEEP WATCHING SOMETHING WHILE
YOU PERFORM ANOTHER TASK.
FOR EXAMPLE, LET'S SAY I'M
WATCHING A LIVE TV PROGRAM ON
RETRO GAMING AND THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT PACMAN AND I
WANT TO SEE IF I CAN INSTALL
AND PLAY THE GAME MYSELF.
I CAN PUT THE LIVE CONTENT
INTO PICTURE-IN-PICTURE MODE
TO KEEP WATCHING IT AND THEN
GO AHEAD AND PERFORM A VOICE
SEARCH FOR PACMAN.  THIS WILL
THEN GIVE ME AN OPTION TO
INSTALL THE GAME FROM THE
PLAY STORE, ALL AT THE SAME
TIME AS WATCHING THE CONTENT.
IT'S PRETTY COOL.
NOTIFICATIONS IS ANOTHER AREA
WE'VE WORKED ON TO IMPROVE
PRODUCTIVITY IN ANDROID AND
IT TURNS OUT THAT TODAY OVER
HALF OF THE NOTIFICATIONS
SHOWN IN ANDROID ORIGINATE
FROM MESSAGING APPLICATIONS.
SO WE DECIDED TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO REALLY OPTIMIZE
FOR THIS USE CASE.
WE'VE ADDED A NEW DIRECT
REPLY FEATURE WHICH LETS YOU
QUICKLY REPLY TO A MESSAGE
LIKE SO.
YOU NO LONGER NEED TO LAUNCH
THE APP TO FIRE OFF A QUICK
RESPONSE, SO IT'S A REAL TIME
SAVER.  WE'VE ALSO ADDED A
FEATURE TO GIVE YOU MORE
CONTROL OVER NOTIFICATIONS.
WITH N, YOU CAN LONG-TAP A
NOTIFICATION TO CHANGE ITS
VISIBILITY.  FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
CAN BLOCK NOTIFICATIONS FROM
A GIVEN APP OR SET THEM TO
SHOW ONLY SILENTLY.  SO NOW
YOU'RE ABLE TO CHOOSE WHICH
APPLICATION -- WHICH
NOTIFICATIONS ARE IMPORTANT
FOR YOU.
ONE OTHER AREA WE'VE WORKED
ON TO IMPROVE YOUR
PRODUCTIVITY IN ANDROID IS
YOUR ABILITY TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF WITH EMOJI AND
ANDROID IS THE FIRST MOBILE
PLATFORM TO SUPPORT THE NEW
UNICODE 9 EMOJI STANDARD.
AND WITH THIS ADDITION ARE
MORE HUMAN-LOOKING GLYPHS AND
SUPPORT FOR SKIN TONE
VARIATIONS.  UNITED KINGDOM 9
ALSO BRINGS 72 NEW EMOJI
GLYPHS, SO NOW YOU CAN LET
YOUR FRIENDS NO, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN YOU'RE DANCING BY THE
LEFT SHARK AND EATING AVOCADO
TOAST, BASICALLY MY TYPICAL
FRIDAY NIGHT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOT!
BUT MORE SERIOUSLY, WE'RE
REALLY COMMITTED TO THIS
SPACE AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE UNICODE
CONSORTIUM ON THE NEXT
GENERATION OF EMOJI.  IN
PARTICULAR, YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
SOME OF OUR SUGGESTIONS
AROUND BETTER REPRESENTING
WOMEN IN PROFESSIONAL ROLES,
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT FOR THAT SO FAR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT.  LET'S WRAP UP.
ANDROID N IS THE BEST VERSION
OF ANDROID YET.  I HAVE TO
SAY THAT.  BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
TRUE.  WE'VE MADE IT FASTER
AND MORE PERFORMANT WITH THE
POWERFUL NEW JIT COMPILER AND
VULKAN 3D GRAPHICS.  WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HARDEN OUR
SECURITY AND PROVIDE THE
FIRST TRULY SEAMLESS SOFTWARE
UPDATE SYSTEM FOR MOBILE.
AND WE'RE MAKING USERS MORE
PRODUCTIVE.
WITH BETTER MULTITASKING,
BRAND-NEW MULTI-WINDOW
SUPPORT AND IMPROVED
NOTIFICATIONS.
IN FACT, THERE ARE OVER 250
MAJOR NEW FEATURES IN N.
EVERYTHING FROM JAVA 8
LANGUAGE SUPPORT TO DATA
SAVER, SETTING SUGGESTIONS
AND MUCH, MUCH MORE.
YOU CAN CHECK OUT THE "WHAT'S
NEW IN ANDROID" SESSION LATER
TODAY TO LEARN EVEN MORE.
WE'RE STILL PUTTING THE FINAL
TOUCHES ON THE N RELEASE AND
WE EXPECT TO LAUNCH IT LATER
THIS SUMMER, BUT IF YOU CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THEN, I'M HAPPY
TODAY TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE'RE
PUBLISHING OUR FIRST
BETA-QUALITY RELEASE
CANDIDATE FOR YOU TO TRY OUT
ON YOUR MAIN PHONE OR TABLET.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO OPT INTO
THE NEW BETA PROGRAM AT
WWW.ANDROID.COM/BETA AND RUN
N ON YOUR NEXUS 6, 9, 5X, 6P,
NEXUS PLAYER, AND PIXEL C.
NOW, THERE'S ONE MORE AREA IN
N THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD ON THAT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT YET.
AND TO TELL YOU MORE ABOUT
WHAT IT IS AND HOW IT FITS
INTO OUR BIGGER PLANS, LET ME
INVITE UP CLAY BAVOR.  THANK
YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Clay Bavor:
THANK YOU,
DAVE.  I'M CLAY BAVOR, AND I
LEAD THE VIRTUAL REALITY TEAM
AT GOOGLE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
AND, YEAH, JUST TO GET RIGHT
TO IT, VIRTUAL REALITY IS
COMING TO ANDROID N.
[ CHEERS ]
SO IT ALL ACTUALLY STARTED AT
A GOOGLE I/O TWO YEARS AGO
WITH CARDBOARD.  AND SINCE
PRETTY AMAZING THINGS.  THERE
ARE MILLIONS OF THEM OUT
THERE IN THE WORLD, IN ALL
SHAPES AND SIZES.
WE'VE ENABLED THOUSANDS OF
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD THEIR
FIRST VR APP, AND USERS HAVE
INSTALLED OVER 50 MILLION
CARDBOARD-ENABLED APPS.
WE THINK THAT'S PRETTY GOOD
FOR WHAT IS, AFTER ALL, JUST
A PIECE OF CARDBOARD.
NOW, WE LOVE CARDBOARD, AND
FOR US, IT REPRESENTS SO MUCH
OF WHAT WE THINK VR SHOULD BE
ABOUT.  IT SHOULD BE MOBILE.
IT SHOULD BE APPROACHABLE, IT
SHOULD BE FOR EVERYONE.
BUT WE KNEW IT WAS JUST A
START BECAUSE THERE'S A LIMIT
TO HOW MUCH YOU CAN DO, HOW
IMMERSIVE AN EXPERIENCE YOU
CAN CREATE WITH CARDBOARD AND
WITH PHONES THAT WERE REALLY
ONLY MEANT TO BE PHONES.
WE WANTED TO CREATE SOMETHING
WHICH HAS THE BEST ATTRIBUTES
OF CARDBOARD BUT WHICH IS
ALSO COMFORTABLE, RICHLY
INTERACTIVE AND FAR MORE
IMMERSIVE.
BUT TO CREATE THAT KIND OF
IMMERSION, YOU HAVE TO SOLVE
-- TO MAKE YOUR BRAIN SAY,
YEP, I'M SOMEWHERE ELSE, YOU
HAVE TO SOLVE A LOT OF REALLY
HARD PROBLEMS ACROSS ALL
PARTS OF THE VR EXPERIENCE.
YOU HAVE TO DESIGN A SYSTEM
THAT'S CAPABLE OF RENDERING
AT VERY HIGH FRAME RATES AND
RESOLUTION.  TO MAKE THE
EXPERIENCE REALLY KIVEL YOU
HAVE TO MINIMIZE WHAT'S
CALLED MOTION TO PHOTON
LATENCY.  THAT'S THE DELAY
BETWEEN WHEN THE MOVE YOUR
HEAD AND WHEN THE PICTURE
UPDATES TO REFLECT THAT
MOTION.  AND YOU YOU NEED TO
SOLVE FOR HOW YOU INTERACT
WITH THINGS IN VR.  AND WHEN
YOU NAIL THOSE THINGS  IT
JUST FEELS LIKE YOU'RE THERE.
WELL, WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THESE PROBLEMS AND MORE.  AND
WHAT WE'VE BUILT WON'T BE
AVAILABLE UNTIL THIS FALL,
BUT WE'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO IT TODAY.  WE CALL IT
DAYDREAM.
DAYDREAM IS OUR PLATFORM FOR
HI
HIGH QUALITY MOBILE VIRTUAL
REALITY, AND IN IT ARE ALL
THE INGREDIENTS YOU NEED TO
HAVE IMMERSIVE VR EXPERIENCE.
OVER TIME DAYDREAM WILL
ENCOMPASS VR IN MANY
DIFFERENT SAIPS AND SIZES BUT
TOOS IT'S HOW IT WILL ENABLE
VR ON SMARTPHONES.
AND THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF
IT.  THE SMARTPHONES
THEMSELVES INCLUDING VR
OPTIMIZATION TO ANDROID N.  A
REFERENCE DESIGN FOR HEADSET
AND CONTROLLER.  AND APPS,
BOTH HOW YOU GET THEM THROUGH
GOOGLE PLAY AND THE APPS
THEMSELVES.  WE'VE DESIGNED
AND BUILT EACH PART IN
CONCERT WITH THE OTHERS WITH
A FOCUS ON GETTING THE
END-TO-END USER EXPERIENCE
JUST RIGHT.
SO LET'S START WITH SMOAPS.
THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS
LOOK AT WHAT IT TAKES TO
BUILD A SMARTPHONE THAT'S
GREAT AT BEING A SMARTPHONE
BUT ALSO AT BEING THE CORE OF
A VR SYSTEM.   AND WITH INPUT
FROM THE MAJOR SILICON
VENDORS AND SMARTPHONE
MANUFACTURERS, WE'VE CREATED
A SET OF PHONE SPECIFICATIONS
FOR VR.  AND WE CALL PHONES
THAT MEET THESE SPECS
DAYDREAM-READY.
AND THE SPECS INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE HIGH PERFORMANCE SENSORS
FOR ACCURATE HEAD TRACKING,
DISPLAYS WITH A FAST RESPONSE
TIME TO MINIMIZE BLUR, AND
POWERFUL MOBILE PROCESSORS.
AND IF A PHONE MEETS THESE
SPECS, IT WILL BE CAPABLE OF
DELIVERING A GREAT VR
EXPERIENCE.
BUT THE SMARTPHONE ITSELF,
IT'S ONLY PART OF THE STORY.
THE OPERATING SYSTEM, THE
SOFTWARE, IT NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE USE OF ALL OF THESE
CAPABILITIES, ALL WHILE
KEEPING LATENCY TO AN
ABSOLUTE MINIMUM.
SO WE'VE INTRODUCED WHAT WE
CALL VR MODE AS PART OF
ANDROID
ANDROID N.  AND WE'VE WORKED
AT ALL LEVELS OF THE ANDROID
STACK TO OPTIMIZE IT FOR VR.
AND WE FOCUSED IN PARTICULAR
ON PERFORMANCE AND LATENCY,
WHICH REBROUGHT DOWN TO UNDER
20 MILLISECONDS.
BY ADDING THINGS LIKE
SINGLE BUFFER RENDERING, AND
VR SYSTEM UI, SO
NOTIFICATIONS AND ALERTS COME
THROUGH PROPERLY IN VR.  AND
ALL OF THIS MAKES FOR A
REALLY COMFORTABLE VR
EXPERIENCE THAT WE THINK
USERS ARE GOING TO LOVE.
NOW, IT'S IMPORTANT, THESE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE PART OF THE
CORE OF ANDROID N, SO THE
ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM CAN BENEFIT.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
DEVELOPERS IS THERE ARE GOING
TO BE A LOT OF DAYDREAM-READY
PHONES.  IN FACT, SAMSUNG,
ALCATEL, ASUS, HTC, HUE WEI,
LG, XIAOMI, ALL WILL HAVE
PHONES COMPATIBLE WITH THE
DAYDREAM-READY SPEC AND
SEVERAL WILL BE READY THIS
FALL.   CHEEP CHEERP.
SO THAT'S PHONES WITH
DAYDREAM-READY PHONE SPECS
AND THE VR OPTIMIZEIZATIONS
AS PART OF DROIRN.
LET'S TURN TO HEADSETS.  THIS
IS OBVIOUS BUT A HEADSET  IS
SOMETHING YOU WEAR ON YOUR
HEAD.  AND BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU WEAR,
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS YOU
NEED TO GET JUST RIGHT.  IT
HAS TO HAVE GREAT OPTICS.  IT
HAS TO BE COMFORTABLE.  THE
MATERIALS NEED TO FEEL GOOD.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE REALLY
EASY TO PUT ON AND TAKE OFF.
WE'VE TAKEN WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED IN ALL OF THESE AREAS
AND WE'VE CREATED A REFERENCE
DESIGN FOR HEADSETS THAT WILL
WORK ALAN EUSTACELY WITH
DAYDREAM-READY ALAN SEAMLESSLY
WITH
DAYDREAM-READY PHONES.  AND
WE'RE SHARING THE DESIGN WITH
PARTNERS ACROSS THE ECOSYSTEM
AND THERE ARE BE SEVERAL
AVAILABLE THIS FALL.   NOW,
WHEN IT COMES TO VR, EVERYONE
THINKS ABOUT HEADSETS, BUT
THE CONTROLLER, HOW YOU
INTERACT WITH VR, IT'S JUST
AS IMPORTANT.  AND WE WANTED
TO CREATE A CONTROLLER THAT'S
OPTIMIZED FOR VR, THAT'S BOTH
POWERFUL AND INTUITIVE.  AND
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON A
CONTROLLER FOR DAYDREAM.  IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS.
AND IF WE ACTUALLY ZOOM IN A
LITTLE BIT, YOU CAN SEE THE
CONTROLLER ITSELF, IT'S VERY
SIMPLE.  THERE ARE FEW
BUTTONS AND A CLICKABLE
TOUCHPAD SO YOU CAN SCROLL
AND SWIPE.  BUT HIDDEN INSIDE
THE CONTROLLER IS THE MAGIC.
WE'VE BUILT IN ORIENTATION
SENSORS SO IT KNOWS WHERE
IT'S POINTING, HOW IT'S
TURNING.  AND YOU CAN DO SOME
PRETTY AWESOME THINGS WITH
IT.  LET'S HAVE A LOOK.
[ VIDEO PLAYING
]
>>Clay Bavor:
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO AS YOU CAN
SEE, THE CONTROLLER, IT'S
SUPER FLEXIBLE, AND THE
DEVELOPERS WE'VE SHARED IT
WITH ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
NOW THE CONTROLLER, TOO, WILL
BE PART OF THE REFERENCE
DESIGN THAT WE'RE SHARING
WITH PARTNERS, WITH THE FIRST
AVAILABLE THIS FALL.
OKAY.  SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
SMARTPHONES AND OPERATING
SYSTEMS, HEADSETS AND
CONTROLLERS.  BUT ULTIMATELY,
THAT'S NOT WHAT VR IS ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN
EXPERIENCE.
SO LET'S TURN TO APPS, WHAT
YOU CAN DO IN VR.
NOW, FIRST, IF YOU'RE A
DEVELOPER, YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT UPSTREAM, FROM
SOMEONE USING YOUR APP OR
PLAYING YOUR GAME.  USERS
HAVE TO FIND IT IN A STORE,
BUY IT, INSTALL IT, LAUNCH
IT.  WELL, THIS WILL ALL WORK
SEAMLESSLY IN DAYDREAM.  AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE'VE BUILT
GOOGLE PLAY FOR VR.
USERS WILL BE ABLE TO BROWSE
AND SEARCH AND BUY AND
INSTALL VR APPS IN VR.  AND
ONCE YOU'VE INSTALLED AN APP,
YOU CAN KEEP COMING BACK TO
IT FROM WHAT WE CALL DAYDREAM
HOME, WHICH GIVES YOU ACCESS
TO ALL OF YOUR FAVORITE GAMES
AND APPS.
LET'S ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE APPS, THE
THINGS YOU CAN DO AND THE
PLACES YOU CAN GO.
OUR PARTNERS LIKE THE NEW
YORK TIMES AND THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL AND CNN ARE
BRINGING THEIR VR APPS TO
DAYDREAM SO YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
EXPERIENCE THE WORLD'S NEWS
LIKE YOU'RE ACTUALLY THERE.
HULU, NETFLIX, HBO, EVEN IMAX
ARE BRINGING THEIR LIBRARIES
TO DAYDREAM, SO YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO WATCH SHOWS AND
MOVIES IN A VIRTUAL CINEMA OR
AN IMMERSIVE 3D FILM IN A
VIRTUAL IMAX THEATER.  THIS
IS ONE OF THE DOZEN IMAX
FILMS THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT
I'M PRETTY FIRED UP ABOUT
HANGING OUT WITH ASTRONAUTS
IN VR.
SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S GOING
TO BE PRETTY AWESOME IN
DAYDREAM IS GAMES.  WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE LIKES
OF EUBIE SOFT, CCP, NETEASE
AND ELECTRONIC ARTS, AND
THESE AMAZING DEVELOPERS ARE
CREATING GAMES THAT TAKE
ADVANTAGE A OF ALL THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT AND THERE ARE
SOME AMAZING THINGS IN THE
WORKS.  WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING ON ON SOME OF OUR OWN
APPS.  GOOGLE PLAY MOVIES IS
COMING TO DAYDREAM COMPLETE
WITH HIGH DEFINITION DRM
VIDEO SUPPORT.  THAT MEANS
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WATCH
MOVIES AND TV SHOWS FROM PLAY
BUT IN A VIRTUAL MOVIE
THEATER.
STREETVIEW IS COMING TO
DAYDREAM, SO YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO WALK THE STREETS OF THE
WORLD WITHOUT HAVING TO FLY
AROUND THE WORLD.  AND GOOGLE
PHOTOS WILL SUPPORT VR PHOTOS
SO YOU CAN STEP INSIDE AND
RELIVE FAVORITE MOMENTS.
AND THERE'S ONE MORE.
YOUTUBE.  WE'VE REBUILT
YOUTUBE FROM THE GROUND UP
FOR VR.  IN IT IS VOICE
SEARCH, DISCOVERY, YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYLISTS; AGAIN,
ALL IN VR.  AND WE'VE ADDED
SPATIAL AUDIO, IMPROVED VR
VIDEO STREAMING SO YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO STEP INSIDE THE
WORLD'S LARGEST COLLECTION OF
VR VIDEOS AND EXPERIENCE
PLACES AND CONCERTS AND
EVENTS LIKE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
THERE.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU'LL ALSO
BE ABLE TO WATCH EVERY SINGLE
STANDARD VIDEO CURRENTLY ON
YOUTUBE, BUT IN A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY.  AND WE THINK
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOVE IT.
SO THAT'S DAYDREAM, OUR
PLATFORM FOR HIGH-QUALITY
MOBILE VIRTUAL REALITY.
DAYDREAM-READY SMARTPHONES
WITH VR OPSIZATIONS
OPTIMIZATIONS AS PART
OF ANDROID N, A COMFORTABLE
HEADSET AND CONTROLLER AND
SOME AMAZING EXPERIENCES.
ALL DESIGNED IN CONCERT AND
OPEN AND AT THE SCALE OF
ANDROID.
NOW, DAYDREAM ARRIVES THIS
FALL BUT YOU CAN  GET STARTED
DEVELOPING FOR IT TODAY WITH
THE LATEST ANDROID DEVELOPER
PREVIEW.  AND WE'LL GO INTO
THAT, AND MORE, TOMORROW HERE
AT 9:00 A.M.
SO THAT'S IT FOR VR AND
ANDROID.  TO TELL YOU ABOUT
WEARABLES AND ANDROID, I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO DAVID
SINGLETON.
THANKS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
>>David Singleton: THANKS,
]CLAY.  WE LAUNCHED DROID WEAR
AT I/O TWO YEARS AGO AND
SINCE THEN, WE'VE PARTNERED
WITH 12 BRANDS TO PAIR
DISTINCTIVE STYLES WITH THE
LATEST IN WEARABLE
TECHNOLOGY.  AND THE RESULT
IS AN IMPRESSIVE COLLECTION
OF OVER 100 DIFFERENT
BEAUTIFUL DESIGNS.  SO
WHETHER YOU ADMIRE THE
HERITAGE OF TAG HEUER OR THE
ICONIC DESIGN OF MICHAEL KORS
KORS, SPEND YOUR TIME HIKING
A TRAIL OR RIDING A WAVE, YOU
CAN WEAR WHAT YOU WANT.  AND
ANDROID WEAR WORKS WITH
ANDROID AND iPHONES BECAUSE
NO MATTER WHAT PHONE YOU
CARRY IN YOUR POCKET, YOU
SHOULD ALWAYS BE ABLE TO WEAR
WHAT YOU WANT ON YOUR WRIST.
AND TODAY I'M SHOWING A
PREVIEW OF OUR BIGGEST
PLATFORM UPDATE YET.  ANDROID
WEAR 2.0.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS,
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE WANT AND DON'T
WANT FROM A WATCH.  WE KNOW
THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT ROLE
OF YOUR WATCH IS HELPING YOU
STAY CONNECTED TO WHAT
MATTERS, TO IMPORTANT, TIMELY
INFORMATION, TO THE PEOPLE
YOU LOVE, AND TO YOUR HEALTH
ALL FROM YOUR WRIST.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE EVOLVING
THE PLATFORM TO BUILD EVEN
BETTER EXPERIENCES FOR THE
WATCH FACE, MESSAGING, AND
FITNESS.  ANDROID WEAR
ALREADY HAS THOUSANDS OF
WATCH FACES YOU CAN DOWNLOAD
AND NOW WE'RE MAKING THEM
EVEN MORE USEFUL BY LETTING
ANY WATCH FACE SHOW DATA FROM
ANY APP.  SO NOW YOU CAN MIX
AND MATCH THE STYLES YOU LOVE
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT'S
MOST USEFUL TO YOU.  LET'S
TAKE A LOOK.
JEFF CHANG FROM THE WEAR TEAM
HAS THE NEWEST LG WATCH WITH
LTE.  AND HERE YOU CAN SEE A
WATCH FACE FROM ZUHANDEN.
JEFF HAS CUSTOMIZED IT WITH
HIS CALL LEE COUNT FROM
LIFESUM, STOCK INFORMATION
FROM ROBINHOOD, AND HIS TASKS
FROM TODOIST.  IF HE WANTS TO
SEE OTHER TASKS FOR TODAY, HE
SIMPLY TAPS RIGHT THERE ON
THE WATCH FACE AND SEES A
REMINDER TO CALL MOM.
AND WATCHES ARE UNIQUELY
SUITED TO CONNECT US TO THOSE
PEOPLE WE LOVE.  YOU'LL NEVER
MISS A CALL FROM YOUR CHILD'S
SCHOOL OR A MESSAGE FROM A
CLOSE FRIEND.  AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE REDESIGNING KEY
EXPERIENCING ON THE WATCH TO
BE EVEN MORE INTUITIVE AND
ENABLING NEW WAYS TO RESPOND
TO MESSAGES DESIGNED JUST FOR
YOUR WRIST.
THIS INCLUDES SMART REPLY,
THAT KNOWS THE CONTEXT OF
YOUR MESSAGE, BEST-IN-CLASS
HANDWRITING RECOGNITION AND A
NEW KEYED
BOARD HERE'S WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN JEFF GETS
A MESSAGE FROM A FRIEND.  HE
HAPPENS TO REPLY, CHOOSES
HANDWRITING INPUT AND NOW HE
USES HIS FINGER TO SKETCH BIG
LETTERS ON THE WATCH AND THE
TEXT RECOGNIZE AUTOMATICALLY
AND NOW SHE KNOWS WITH ONE
MORE GO SHE KNOWS THAT HE'LL
BE THERE
AT 3:00 P.M.
>>> MANY OF YOU WANT YOUR
WATCH TO  MANY
OF YOU WANT BE LIKE A PERSONAL
COACH, HELPING YOUR YOU STAY
AWARE, MOTIVATED AND
CONNECTED TO YOUR BODIESOME.
FIRST, WE'RE IMPROVING WATCH
THE
FITNESS EXPERIENCE WITH
GOOGLEFIT PLATFORMS WITH
AUTOMATIC ACTIVITY
RECOGNITION.  SECOND, YOUR
APPS CAN
EXCHANGE DATA USING
THE GOOGLEFIT API, SO
INFORMATION LIKE CALORIES
CONSUMEDWATCHED IN A NUTRITION
APP
WITH SYNC WITH CALORIES
BURNED IN A RUNNING APP AND
FINALLY, WE'RE EXPANDING THE
WAYS YOU CAN ENJOY LISTENING
TO MUSIC WHILE YOU WORK OUT.
EVEN WHEN YOU LEAVE YOUR
PHONE BEHIND.
WHEN YOU WANT TO GO FOR A
RUN, JUST GO WITH THE WATCH
YOU'RE ALREADY WEARING.  NO
NEED TO STRAP YOUR PHONE IN
AN AWKWARD ARMBAND.  AND
THANKS TO THE HARDWARE
SENSORS ON YOUR WATCH AND
AUTOMATIC ACTIVITY
RECOGNITION, APPS LIKE STRAVA
WILL START TRACKING YOUR TIME
AND DISTANCE WHEN YOU START
RUNNING.  AND IF YOU ENJOY
MUSIC WHILE WORKING OUT, YOU
CAN LAUNCH SPOTIFY RIGHT FROM
YOUR WATCH FACE.
[ MUSIC ]
AND THE BEST PART OF ALL OF
THIS, YOU DON'T EVEN NEED A
PHONE.  IN FACT, WHEN JEFF
WAS SHOWING YOU THE DEMOS,
HIS PHONE WAS TURNED OFF!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND EVERYTHING YOU SAW HERE
TODAY, FROM SENDING MESSAGES
TO STREAMING MUSIC WORKED ON
JUST HIS WATCH.
WITH ANDROID WEAR 2.0, APPS
CAN BE STAND-ALONE.  THAT
MEANS THE APPS ON YOUR WATCH
CAN HAVE DIRECT NETWORK
ACCESS TO THE CLOUD VIA
BLUETOOTH, WiFi, OR A
CELLULAR CONNECTION.  AND
THAT MEANS A FAST AND RICHER
ON-WATCH APP EXPERIENCE FOR
BOTH ANDROID AND iPHONE
USERS.
WITH STAND-ALONE APPS,
WATCHES WITH CELLULAR SUPPORT
BECOME EVEN MORE POWERFUL.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE CALLS,
GET HELP FROM GOOGLE, AND USE
YOUR FAVORITE APPS RIGHT ON
THE WATCH, NO MATTER WHERE
YOUR PHONE IS OR EVEN IF IT'S
ON OR OFF.  STARTING TODAY
DEVELOPERS
CAN DOWNLOAD A PREVIEW OF
ANDROID WEAR 2.0 AND EVERYONE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENJOY THESE
EXPERIENCES IN THE FALL.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO REIMAGINE
WHAT'S POSSIBLE FOR WEARABLES
TOGETHER.  AND WE CAN'T WAIT
TO SEE THE INCREDIBLE THINGS
THAT YOU WILL BUILD.  AND NOW
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE FROM THE
WIDER ANDROID DEVELOPER
COMMUNITY.
[ VIDEO PLAYING. ]
[ VIDEO CONCLUDES ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>Jason Titus: HI. I'M
JASON TITUS I LEAD OUR
DEVELOPER PRODUCT GROUP HERE
AT GOOGLE.  AND AS YOU CAN
SEE, SOFTWARE DEVELOPERS ARE
CHANGING OUR WORLD IN A BIG
WAY.  IN FACT, IT'S HARD TO
FIND AN ASPECT OF OUR LIVES
THAT HASN'T BEEN TOUCHED FROM
HOW WE LEARN TO HOW WE GET
AROUND, TO HOW WE MEET
PEOPLE.  YOU ARE CONSTANTLY
FINDING WAYS TO USE KNEW NEW
AND
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES TO
IMPROVE OUR LIVES.
DESPITE ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES,BUT IT'S REALLY
HARD TO GO
FROM AN IDEA TO BUILDING A
GREAT PRODUCT TO GETTING IT
IN USER'S HANDS.  SO I'D LIKE
TO SHARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST YEAR TO MAKE THIS
PROCESS EASIER ON ANY
PLATFORM.
LET'S START WITH THE WEB.
THE SHIFT TO MOBILE FOR THE
WEB PLATFORM IS WELL
UNDERWAY, WITH OVER -- WE'VE
RECENTLY HIT A MILESTONE WITH
OVER A BILLION PEOPLE USING
CHROME ON MOBILE EVERY MONTH.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON SEVERAL
INITIATIVES TO TRY AND MAKE
THE WEBWORK BETTER ON MOBILE
DEVICES.  I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TWO OF THEM.
FIRST, WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
POWERFUL NEW WEB STANDARDS IN
CHROME THAT ENABLE A NEW
CLASS OF WEB SITE TO GAIN APP
LIKE BEHAVIOR.  LIKE WORKING
RELIABLY ON EVEN THE WORST
NETWORKING CONNECTION OR
SENDING NOTIFICATIONS TO
RE-ENGAGE USERS.
WE CALL WEB SITES THAT USE
THESE FEATURES PROGRESSIVE
WEB APPS, BECAUSE THEY GET
PROGRESSIVELY BETTER
DEPENDING ON THE CAPABILITY
OF THE WEB BROWSERS, AND THEY
CAN LEAD TO DRAMATICALLY
BETTER USER EXPERIENCES.
SECOND, WE CREATED AN OPEN
SOURCE PROJECT CALLED
ACCELERATED MOBILE PAGES OR
AMP, TO MAKE IT SIMPLE TO
CREATE EXTREMELY FAST MOBILE
WEB SITES USING EXISTING WEB
STANDARDS.
ON AVERAGE, AMP PAGES LOAD
FOUR TIMES FASTER AND USE
ONE-TENTH AS MUCH DATA.
THESE THINGS LOAD ALMOST
INSTANTLY.  SO WE'RE MAKING
IT EASIER TO DEVELOP MOBILE
WEB SITES, BUT WE'RE ALSO
INVESTING IN NATIVE
DEVELOPMENT.  WE WANT ANDROID
STUDIO TO BE THE QUICKEST,
MOST RELIABLE WAY TO BUILD
ANDROID APPS.  I'D LIKE TO
INVITE STEPH UP TO TELL YOU
MORE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Stephanie Cuthbertson:
THANKS, JASON.  I'M STEPH.  I
WORK ON THE ANDROID TEAM.
ANDROID STUDIO IS OUR
OFFICIAL IDE.  IT'S
PURPOSE-BUILT FOR ANDROID.
AND IT WAS ONLY THREE YEARS
AGO, RIGHT HERE AT I/O, THAT
WE SHOWED IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
SINCE THEN, IT HAS BUILT A
TON OF MOMENTUM.
92% OF THE TOP 125 APPS AND
GAMES NOW USE ANDROID STUDIO.
AND MILLIONS OF DEVELOPERS
WORLDWIDE.
OUR ANDROID ENGINEERING TEAM
SEES THAT ALMOST ALL THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPERS THAT
WE CONNECT WITH HAVE USED IT
AND SWITCHED OVER FROM OUR
ECLIPSE TOOLS.
YOUR FEEDBACK HAS BEEN
AWESOME BECAUSE IT'S HELPED
US FOCUS ON THE RIGHT THINGS.
WE CARE A LOT ABOUT MAKING IT
GREAT.  AND THERE'S MUCH MORE
TO COME.
THIS MORNING, WE'LL RELEASE
OUR LATEST, WHICH IS ANDROID
STUDIO'S 2.2 PREVIEW.
FOCUSING ON SPEED, SMARTS,
AND ANDROID PLATFORM SUPPORT.
FIRST, SPEED.
ALREADY WITH 2.1 WE MADE
BUILDING AND RUNNING CHANGES
10 TIMES FASTER THAN IT WAS
ONLY SIX MONTHS AGO.  OUR NEW
INSTANT RUN FEATURE DROVE
MOST OF THIS.  NOW WHEN YOU
HIT "RUN" WE DEPLOY CHANGES
DIRECTLY INTO THE RUNNING
APP.  THE EMULATORS ARE THREE
TIMES FASTER AND PUSH SPEEDS
ARE EVEN FASTER THAN THAT.
SO ALL OF THAT MEANS THE
EMULATORS ARE NOW ACTUALLY
FASTER THAN THE PHYSICAL
DEVICE THAT'S PROBABLY IN
YOUR POCKET RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE WANT TO KEEP SPEEDING
YOU UP TO LAUNCH EARLIER.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
TOLD US IS THAT WE COULD NOT
POSSIBLY MAKE BUILD SPEEDS
TOO FAST.
SO WITH 2.2 WE'RE GOING TO
ACCELERATE BUILD SPEEDS
AGAIN.  PLUS WE KNOW INSTANT
RUN'S A LONG-TERM BET SO
WE'LL KEEP EXPANDING
COVERAGE.
ANOTHER THING WE WANT TO DO
IS MAKE IT EASIER TO WRITE
TESTS TO HELP DRIVE UP APP
QUALITY.  SO WITH TEST
RECORDING, NOW AS YOU JUST
TAP THROUGH YOUR APP, WE'LL
RECORD -- WE'LL WRITE ALL OF
YOUR ESPRESSO TEST CODE FOR
YOU.  ALMOST -- IT'S
BASICALLY AS IF --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT'S AS IF YOU HAD
HANDWRITTEN THE CODE YOURSELF
AND YOU CAN RUN THOSE TESTS
LOCALLY OR YOU CAN RUN THEM
WITH OUR IDE-INTEGRATED CLOUD
TEST LAB, TO MAKE SURE YOUR
APP RUNS WELL ON MANY ANDROID
DEVICES.
NOW, ONE OF THE THINGS THE
ENGINEERING TEAM IS MOST
EXCITED ABOUT IS THAT WITH
2.2 YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD LAYOUTS FASTER AND
THEY'LL RUN FASTER, TOO.  SO
LET ME SHOW YOU THIS.
2.2 INCLUDES A REWRITTEN
FEATURE-RICH LAYOUT DESIGNER,
WITH NEW CONSTRAINT LAYOUTS.
SO WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
HERE IS YOU'LL BE ABLE TO USE
THE LAYOUT WINDOW.  IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A SHEET OF PAPER.
SO YOU CAN POSITION YOUR
WIDGETS AND ONCE YOU'RE
HAPPY, YOU'LL SEE HERE WE
SAVE YOU A TON OF TIME
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
AUTOMATICALLY ADD ALL THE
CONSTRAINTS FOR YOU, DOING A
BUNCH OF ACTUALLY VERY COOL
MATH UNDER THE COVERS.
YOU'LL SEE THE UI HERE IS NOW
GOING TO ADAPT SO YOU CAN TRY
IT ON DIFFERENT ANDROID
ADVICES.  IT WILL ADAPT TO
DIFFERENT ORIENTATIONS.  BUT
WHAT YOU CAN'T SEE IS BEHIND
THE SCENES YOUR APP WILL RUN
FASTER, TOO.
SO MANY OF YOU HERE ARE
PROFESSIONAL ANDROID
DEVELOPERS AND YOU KNOW
BUILDING RICH UI USUALLY
REQUIRES NESTED LAYOUTS AND
THOSE ARE HARD TO
PERFORMANCE-TUNE AT TIMES.
WITH CONSTRAINT LAYOUTS,
THERE IS NO NESTING REQUIRED,
SO OVERALL YOU GET THE SAME
RICH UI, LESS WORK, AND
BETTER PERFORMANCE BY
DEFAULT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SECOND, SMARTS.  WE WANT TO
HELP YOU WRITE BETTER ANDROID
APPS.  THE 2.2 PREVIEW
INCLUDES A NEW APK ANALYZER
SO YOU CAN FIGURE OUT, "HEY,
WHAT'S MAKING MY APP SO BIG?"
THIS IS REALLY USEFUL FOR ALL
OF YOU WHO ARE TARGETING
EMERGING MARKETS.  YOU'VE
TALKED TO US A LOT ABOUT
THIS.  YOU ALSO HAD ASKED FOR
A LAYOUT INSPECTOR SO WE HAVE
A NEW LAYOUT INSPECTOR IN 2.2
SO YOU CAN FIND OUT WHAT'S
INSIDE YOUR ANDROID LAYOUTS.
WHEN YOU RUN CODE ANALYSES,
YOU'LL FIND A BUNCH OF NEW
QUALITY CHECKS, AND THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE 260 THAT ARE
ALREADY THERE, ALL DESIGNED
TO ELIMINATE COMMON CLASSES
OF ERRORS THAT WE SEE ON
ANDROID.
AND WE INTEGRATED THE LATEST
VERSION OF THE WONDERFUL
INTELLIJ IDE, 2016.1.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE THIRD THING I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS ANDROID
PLATFORM SUPPORT.  SO WE
DEVELOPED THE IDE RIGHT
ALONGSIDE THE PLATFORM, SO WE
CAN BRING YOU THE VERY BEST.
2.2 INCLUDES, TO NAME JUST A
FEW, SUPPORT FOR N'S NEW JACK
COMPILER WHICH IS BRINGING
YOU WONDERFUL JAVA 8 FEATURES
LIKE LAMBDAS, DEFAULT
METHODS.  AND FOR ALL OF YOU
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE
WORKINGGRAPHIC-RICH LIKE
GAMES AND APPS, YOU KNOW C++
IS CRITICAL AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF YOUR REQUESTS WE'VE BEEN
SUBTLY BUILDING OUT C++
SUPPORT.
NOW, WE ALREADY HAVE C++
EDITING AND DEBUGGING, BUT IN
2.2 YOU'LL FIND A MAJOR
CHANGE BASED ON YOUR
FEEDBACK.
IN ADDITION TO GRADLE, FOR
BUILD WE'LL NOW SUPPORT CMAKE
AND NDK BUILD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND BOTH OF THOSE BUILD
SYSTEMS WILL WORK WITH THE
DEBUGGER AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT, WE MADE C++ DEBUGGING
BETTER ALSO.
SO I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
IT, WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT, IF YOU
DOWNLOAD AND TRY ALL OF THIS
TODAY AND GIVE US FEEDBACK.
WITH THAT, I WOULD LOVE TO
PASS IT BACK TO JASON.  THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Jason Titus: THANK YOU,
ITSELF.  IT'S GREAT TO SEE
DROITS
ANDROIDS GETTING SO MUCH
FASTER.  18 MONTHS AGO  WE
ACQUIRED FIREBASE, A GREAT
MOBILE BACK END AS A SERVICE
FOR STORING YOUR APP'S DATA
AND SYNCING IT ACROSS iOS,
ANDROID AND THE WEB.
SINCE THEN, ITS USAGE HAS
GROWN TO OVER 450,000
DEVELOPERS.
WE WOULD REALLY ADMIRE, IT'S
GREAT DEVELOPER EXPERIENCE
AND WE WANTED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BRING THAT TO OTHER
AREAS OF APP DEVELOPMENT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH COMPANIES BIG AND SMALL
ALL OVER THE WORLD TO EXPLORE
HOW WE COULD MAKE OUR
OFFERING BETTER.
TODAY, WE ARE ANNOUNCING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF FIREBASE.
FIREBASE IS --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
FIREBASE IS NOW A SUITE OF
INTEGRATED PRODUCTS TO HELP
YOU BUILD YOUR APP, GROW YOUR
USER BASE, AND EARN MONEY.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST, MOST
COMPREHENSIVE DEVELOPER
UPDATE WE HAVE EVER MADE.
SO AT THE HEART OF THE NEW
FIREBASE IS A MOBILE
ANALYTICS TOOL WE'VE BUILT
FROM THE GROUND UP CALLED
FIREBASE ANALYTICS.  IT'S
INSPIRED BY MUCH OF THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS WITH GOOGLE
ANALYTICS, BUT IT'S DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF APPS.
IT'S GREAT FOR APP DEVELOPERS
FOR A COUPLE OF WAYS.  FIRST,
IT GIVES YOU RICH INSIGHTS
INTO WHAT USERS ARE DOING
INSIDE OF YOUR APP.  AND IT
ALSO TELLS YOU WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM WITH RICH CROSS
NETWORK ATTRIBUTION; ALL OF
THIS IN A SINGLE DASHBOARD.
SECOND, WE'VE CREATED A NEW
FEATURE CALLED FIREBASE
AUDIENCES WHICH INTEGRATES
ALL OF FIREBASE TOGETHER.
WITH FIREBASE AUDIENCES, YOU
CAN GROUP USERS BASED ON THE
CRITERIA THAT MATTERS TO YOU
MOST, AND THEN TAKE ACTION
WITH NOTIFICATIONS,
EXPERIMENTS, AND EVEN
RE-ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGNS ON
ADWORDS.
AND THE BEST PART, FIREBASE
ANALYTICS WORKS ACROSS
ANDROID AND iOS AND IT IS
COMPLETELY FREE AND
UNLIMITED!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
SURROUNDING ANALYTICS ARE
OVER A DOZEN OTHER MAJOR
FEATURES.  I'M GOING TO COVER
SOME HIGHLIGHTS.
FIRST THERE'S CLOUD MESSAGING
AND NOTIFICATIONS, WHICH IS
BUILT ON THE WORLD'S MOST
POPULAR CLOUD-TO-DEVICE
MESSAGING PLATFORM, WITH OVER
ONE MILLION APPS SENDING OVER
170 BILLION MESSAGESES EVERY
DAY.
AND NOW THAT IT'S INTEGRATED
INTO FIREBASE, YOU CAN SEND
TARGETED NOTIFICATIONS TO
YOUR AUDIENCES WITHOUT
WRITING ANY CODE.  AND, LIKE
ANALYTICS, IT IS COMPLETELY
FREE AND
UNLIMITED.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW, APP QUALITY IS IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US.  IF YOUR APP
CRASHES, IT'S BAD FOR YOUR
USERS, AND IT HURTS YOUR
BUSINESS.
WITHIN GOOGLE, TEAMS LIKE
CHROME BUILD AND DEPLOY
ACROSS MULTIPLE PLATFORMS AT
SCALE.  SO WE'VE BUILT ON
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CREATED FIREBASE CRASH
REPORTING.
YOU CAN USE IT TO QUICKLY
IDENTIFY BUGS AND ISSUES, AND
TAKE ACTION TO REDUCE IMPACT
ON YOUR USERS.
ANOTHER ASPECT OF BUILDING A
HIGH-QUALITY APP IS BEING
ABLE TO TUNE AND EXPERIMENT
WITH FEATURES.  SO WE'VE
TAKEN THE SAME INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE USE FOR OUR OWN APPS
AND CREATED FIREBASE REMOTE
CONFIG WHICH LETS YOU CREATE
EXPERIMENTS AND TEST APP
CONFIGURATIONS AT SCALE.
FINALLY, TO HELP YOU GROW,
WE'VE CREATED DYNAMIC LINKS.
A DYNAMIC DYNAMIC LINK IS JUST
A
REGULAR URL WHOSE BEHAVIOR
CAN BE CONFIGURED DEPENDING
UPON WHERE IT'S TAPPED.  IT
PERSISTS THROUGH THE APP
INSTALL PROCESS SO YOU CAN
DRIVE INSTALLS WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING A SUPERIOR USER
EXPERIENCE.
IN THIS EXAMPLE WITH NPR,
WITH DYNAMIC LINKS, WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE WHAT WAS 13 TAPS
DOWN TO ONLY
4.
SO AS I MENTIONED, THERE ARE
OVER A DOZEN FEATURES OF THE
NEW FIREBASE, AND WHILE EACH
OF THEM IS INTERESTING ON ITS
OWN, THE POWER OF FIREBASE IS
IN HOW THEY'RE INTEGRATED
TOGETHER.
HERE'S A QUICK EXAMPLE.
FIRST, WITH CRASH REPORTING,
YOU CAN SEE CRASHES AS
THEY'RE HAPPENING.  THEN IN
ANALYTICS, YOU CAN LOOK AT
WHAT THE IMPACT IS ON YOUR
BUSINESS.  ONCE YOU FIX THE
CRASH, YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE
NOTIFICATIONS TO REACH BACK
OUT AND INVITE USERS BACK
INTO YOUR APP.  OR USE REMOTE
CONFIG TO OFFER THEM A
COUPON.  AND ALL OF THIS IS
INTEGRATED INTO OUR GOOGLE
CLOUD PLATFORM, SO THAT IF
YOU WANT TO DO DEEPER, MORE
CUSTOMIZED ANALYSIS OF YOUR
ANALYTICS DATA, YOU CAN
EXPORT IT TO BIGQUERY,
GOOGLE'S FULLY MANAGED,
PETABYTE SCALE DATA WHITE
WAREHOUSE.
SO I'VE ONLY SKIMMED THE
SURFACE, BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GO INTO DETAIL LATER ON THIS
AFTERNOON, AND WE HAVE OVER
30 SESSIONS ON FIREBASE
THROUGHOUT I/O.
THE NEW FIREBASE IS AVAILABLE
TODAY THROUGH ONE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
THROUGH ONE EASY TO INSTALL
SDK ACROSS ANDROID, iOS,
AND THE WEB.  PLEASE GIVE IT
A TRY.  WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED TO HEAR WHAT YOU
THINK AND WE CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE WHAT YOU BUILD NEXT.
AND WITH THAT, HERE IS ELLIE
TO GIVE YOU A PREVIEW OF A
NEW ANDROID EFFORT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON FOR YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Ellie Powers:
THANKS,
JASON.
HI, EVERYBODY.  I'M ELLIE
FROM THE ANDROID TEAM.  AND
I'M HERE WITH FICUS
KIRKPATRICK, OUR ENGINEERING
DIRECTOR.
WE HOPE THAT FIREBASE WILL
MAKE IT A LOT EASIER FOR ALL
OF YOU TO BUILD GREAT APPS.
AND WE'RE ALSO THINKING HARD
ABOUT HOW ANDROID APPS SHOULD
EVOLVE AND DO MORE.
WE'LL BE SHOWING YOU A SNEAK
PEEK OF A NEW PROJECT.  WE
THINK IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
HOW PEOPLE EXPERIENCE ANDROID
APPS, AND WE'LL BE BRINGING
IT TO ANDROID USERS AND
DEVELOPERS OVER THE NEXT
YEAR.
DEVELOPERS LIKE ALL OF YOU
HERE HAVE BUILT AMAZING
ANDROID APPS.  THEY UNLEASH
THE FULL POWER OF ANDROID
DEVICES, SEAMLESSLY COMBINING
THE CAMERA, SENSORS, SMOOTH
ANIMATIONS, AND MORE.
BUT YOU'VE REALLY TOLD US
THAT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BRING USERS INTO YOUR APPS
MORE QUICKLY.  WE WANT TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR USERS AND
DEVELOPERS TO CONNECT; FOR
USERS TO ACCESS A WIDER RANGE
OF APPS AND FOR DEVELOPERS TO
REACH MORE PEOPLE.
WITH THE WEB, YOU CAN JUST
CLICK ON A LINK AND LAND ON A
WEB PAGE.  THAT'S ONE CLICK
AND A FEW SECONDS.
WHAT IF YOU COULD RUN ANY APP
WITH ONE TAP?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON.
WE'RE EVOLVING ANDROID APPS
TO RUN INSTANTLY, WITHOUT
INSTALLATION.  WE CALL THIS
ANDROID INSTANT APPS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
WE'RE GOING TO SHARE A QUICK
PREVIEW OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON, AND I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MUCH I'VE BEEN
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
MOMENT FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME.
SO LET'S SAY MY FRIEND
MICHAEL SENDS ME THIS LINK TO
TASTY ON BUZZFEED VIDEO.  AND
LET'S BE COMPLETELY CLEAR.
LET'S BE HONEST WITH EACH
OTHER.  I DO NOT HAVE THE
BUZZFEED VIDEO APP INSTALLED
ON MY PHONE.
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO TAP THE URL,
AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE ME
RIGHT INTO BUZZFEED VIDEO'S
ANDROID APP, WITHOUT
INSTALLING
IT.
FICUS, GO!
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE IS
GOOGLE PLAY IS FETCHING ONLY
THE PIECES OF THE APP THAT WE
NEED RIGHT NOW.
THERE.
[ APPLAUSE
]
WE ARE IN THE ANDROID APP.
AND I DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO
INSTALL IT.  IT WAS PRETTY
FAST TOO; RIGHT?
SO HERE YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT VIDEOS
SHOWING HOW TO MAKE A BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT RECIPES, AND THE
VIDEOS START PLAYING
AUTOMATICALLY.  REMEMBER,
IT'S A REAL ANDROID APP;
RIGHT?  AND I CAN JUST SWIPE
AND GO TO THE NEXT VIDEO
REALLY QUICKLY.
THE APP WAS ABLE TO OPEN SO
FAST BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SPLIT
UP INTO MODULES.  WHEN FICUS
TAPPED THE LINK, GOOGLE PLAY
DOWNLOADED ONLY THE CODE THAT
WAS NECESSARY TO DISPLAY THIS
SCREEN.
AND IF I WANT TO KEEP
BUZZFEED VIDEO ON MY HOME
SCREEN, IT'S SIMPLE TO
INSTALL THE APP RIGHT HERE.
HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
PHOTO AND VIDEO HAS AN
ANDROID APP BUT I DON'T HAVE
IT ON MY PHONE BECAUSE I
DON'T SHOP FOR CAMERAS EVERY
DAY.  IF I'M SEARCHING  FOR
SOMETHING SPECIFIC LIKE A
CAMERA BAG I CAN STILL GET
THAT SAME EXPERIENCE.  WITH
ONE TAP, THE APP OPENS UP
RIGHT TO THE BAGGY WANT TO
BAG I WANT TO
BUY.  TECHNICALLY, THIS IS A
DEEP LINK TO THE ANDROID
ACTIVITY THAT B&H ROTE TO
DISPLAY THIS PAGE.  I CAN
ALSO  SWIPE RIGHT HERE AND
SEE MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
BAG.
NOW, WHEN I ADD IT TO MY
CART, THE ANIMATION THERE WAS
PRETTY SLICK.  AND AT CHOWT
CHECKOUT TIME, DRAIP WORKS
JUST LIKE IF I HAD THE APP
INSTALLED.  I DON'T HAVE TO
PULL OUT MY CREDIT CARD AND
TYPE IN MY NAME AND ADDRESS.
AND DROID INSTANT APPS, ANDROID
INSTANT APPS I'M
ALREADY SIGNED IN AND READY
TO PAY.  SO IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ME TWO TAPS, NOT TWO
MINUTES.
FINALLY --
[ APPLAUSE ]
FINALLY, LET'S SEE HOW
ANDROID INSTANT APPS CAN HELP
ME WHEN I'M OUT AND ABOUT.
SO I WALK UP TO A PARKING
METER AND I NEED TO PAY.  I'M
IN A REAL HURRY TODAY AND I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO INSTALL A
PARKING APP, BUT WHAT IF I
COULD JUST TAP MY PHONE, AND
WITH NFC IT COULD BRING UP
THE PARKING APP IMMEDIATELY?
ALL I HAVE TO DO IS CHOOSE
HOW LONG I WANT TO PARK.  I'M
ALREADY DONE.
AND NOW FICUS CAN RUN OFF THE
STAGE TO HIS MEETING AND EVEN
ADD MORE PARKING TIME LATER
IF HE REALLY NEEDS TO.
SO THAT'S ANDROID INSTANT
APPS.  AS A USER, IT'S
TOTALLY SEAMLESS, FROM
LAUNCHING THE APP, TO SIGNING
IN, TO MAKING PAYMENTS.
NOW, AS A DEVELOPER, YOU'LL
UPDATE YOUR EXISTING APP.
IT'S THE SAME ANDROID APIs,
THE SAME PROJECT, AND THE
SAME SOURCE CODE.  AND IT CAN
TAKE LESS THAN A DAY OF WORK,
DEPENDING ON HOW YOUR APP IS
BUILT.
YOU'RE MODULARIZE YOUR APP
AND GOOGLE PLAY WILL DOWNLOAD
ONLY THE PARTS THAT ARE
NEEDED ON THE FLY, AS YOU SAW
HERE.  WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO GIVE DEVELOPERS MORE WAYS
TO GET THEIR APPS INTO THE
HANDS OF USERS.  IN ADDITION
TO DISCOVERING YOUR APPS IN
THE PLAY STORE AND INSTALLING
THEM, INSTANT APPS WILL
PROVIDE ANOTHER ONRAMP.
PEOPLE CAN CAN USE YOUR
INSTANT APP DIRECTLY, AND AS
WE SHOWED EARLIER, IF THEY
WANT TO INSTALL IT, THAT'S
EASY, TOO.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, YOU WILL BE
IN CONTROL OF THE EXPERIENCES
YOU BUILD.  AND WHEN YOU DO
MAKE THE UPDATE, YOUR APP
WILL BE JUST ONE TAP AWAY FOR
OVER A BILLION
PEOPLE.
OH, YEAH, I ALMOST FORGOT TO
MENTION ONE REALLY IMPORTANT
DETAIL.  SO THIS DEMO THAT
FICUS DID, HE ACTUALLY DID
THAT ON A PHONE RUNNING
KITKAT.
[ APPLAUSE
]
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT INSTANT
APPS IS GOING TO BE
COMPATIBLE ALL THE WAY BACK
TO JELLY BEAN.
AND WE REALLY WANT FOR ALL OF
YOU TO BE ABLE TO TRY THIS,
AND WE'RE REALLY GOING TO
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO YOU JUST
AS SOON AS WE CAN.  BUT IT'S
A BIG CHANGE IN HOW WE THINK
ABOUT APPS.  WE WANT TO GET
IT RIGHT.  AND SO THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME FOR
US.
WE'RE WORKING NOW WITH A
SMALL SET OF DEVELOPERS AND
WE'LL BE GRADUALLY ROLLING
OUT ACCESS AND ACTUALLY
ROLLING OUT INSTANT APPS TO
USERS LATER THIS YEAR.
WE ARE SO EXCITED ABOUT ALL
OF THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THIS WILL OPEN UP, AND WE
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT YOU
ARE GOING TO BUILD WHEN YOUR
APP IS JUST A TAP AWAY.
AND WITH THAT, I'LL HAND IT
BACK TO SUNDAR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>Sundar Pichai: THANK YOU,
JASON AND ELLIE.  FIREBASE IS
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
RDEVELOPER OFFERING WE HAVE
DONE TO DATE.  I'M GLAD IT'S
AVAILABLE TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
FEEDBACK.
WE TALKED A LOT TODAY ABOUT
MACHINE LEARNING AND AI.  WE
THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ACCELERATE COMPUTING BY
WORKING ON THIS WITH EVERYONE
ELSE.  AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT IN TWO WAYS.  FIRST,
WE ARE OPENING UP CORD
COMPONENTS OF OUR MACHINE
LEARNING SYSTEMS.  LAST YEAR,
WE OPEN SOURCED TENSORFLOW SO
DEVELOPERS CAN EMBED MACHINE
LEARNING AND DEEP NEURAL NETS
WITH A SINGLE APIs API.  IN
2015,
IT WAS THE MOST FORKED
PROJECT ON GITHUB, AND IT IS
THE NUMBER ONE MACHINE
LEARNING PROJECT ON THAT
SITE.
LAST WEEK WE OPEN-SOURCED A
NATURAL LANGUAGE PARSER WHICH
IS ALSO BUILT ON TOP OF
TENSORFLOW.  WE ARE DOING
THESE THINGS SO WE CAN ENGAGE
THE EXTERNAL COMMUNITY AND
WORK ON THIS TOGETHER WITH
EVERYONE.
SECOND, FOR DEVELOPERS AND
COMPANIES OUT THERE, WE ARE
ALSO EXPOSING OUR MACHINE
LEARNING CAPABILITIES THROUGH
OUR GOOGLE CLOUD PLATFORM.
WE ALREADY HAVE A CLOUD
MACHINE LEARNING PLATFORM
UNDERWAY, AND YOU GET ACCESS
TO COMPUTER VISION, SPEECH,
LANGUAGE, AND TRANSLATION
APIs.  AND WE ARE WORKING
ON BRINGING MANY MORE MACHINE
LEARNING APIs SO THAT YOU
CAN GET ACCESS TO THE SAME
GREAT CAPABILITIES WE HAVE
INSIDE AT GOOGLE.
WE BELIEVE THIS WILL BE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENTIATORS FOR THE
GOOGLE CLOUD PLATFORM OVER
TIME.  AND, BY THE WAY, WHEN
YOU USE GOOGLE CLOUD
PLATFORM, YOU NOT ONLY GET
ACCESS TO THE GREAT SOFTWARE
WE USE INTERNALLY, YOU GET
ACCESS TO SPECIALIZED
HARDWARE WE BUILD INTERNALLY.
AND TALKING ABOUT THAT, FOR
MACHINE LEARNING, THE SCALE
AT WHICH WE NEED TO DO
COMPUTING IS INCREDIBLE AND
SO WE'VE STARTED BUILDING
SPECIALIZED, CUSTOM HARDWARE.
WE CALL THESE TENSOR
PROCESSING UNITS OR TPUs.
TPUs DELIVER AN ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE HIGHER PERFORMANCE
PER WATT THAN ALL
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE GPUs
AND FPGAs.  AND WHEN YOU
USE THE GOOGLE CLOUD
PLATFORM, YOU GET -- YOU CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF TPUs AS
WELL.
TPUs ARE WHAT POWERED
ALPHAGO, DEEPMIND'S ALPHAGO,
IN ITS GAME AGAINST LEE SEDOL
SEDOL.  GO IS AN ANCIENT
CHINESE BOARD GAME.  IT'S A
SIMPLE 19 BY 19 GRID BUT IT
IS ONE OF THE MOST COMPLEX
GAMES HUMANS HAVE EVER
DESIGNED.  IT HAS MORE
POSSIBLE BOARD
CONFIGURATIONS, MANY MORE
POSSIBLE BOARD CONFIGURATIONS
THAN THERE ARE ATOMS IN THE
UNIVERSE.  BEATING GO FOR
COMPUTERS WAS WIDELY
CONSIDERED TO BE THE GRAND
CHALLENGE FOR AI AND MOST
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WOULDN'T
HAPPEN FOR ANOTHER DECADE OR
SO.
SO WE ARE REALLY THRILLED
THAT ALPHAGO WAS ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THIS MILESTONE
RECENTLY.
ONE THING WORTH CALLING OUT,
IN THE SECOND GAME THERE WAS
A MOVE 37 BY ALPHAGO.  IT
CHANGED THE COURSE OF THE
GAME AND IS NOW WIDELY
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL GO MOVES EVER SEEN
IN TOURNAMENT PLAY.  IT WAS
NOT JUST AN INTUITIVE MOVE
BUT A VERY CREATIVE MOVE.  WE
NORMALLY DON'T ASSOCIATE
COMPUTERS WITH MAKING
CREATIVE CHOICES AND SO TO
US, THIS REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT IN
AI.
BY THE WAY, LEE SEDOL HAS WON
EVERY SINGLE GAME SINCE HE
PLAYED AGAINST ALPHAGO AND HE
HAS EVEN REPLAYED SOME OF THE
MOVES HE LEARNED FROM ALPHAGO
IN THAT GAME.
AS A STATE-OF-THE-ART
CAPABILITIES IN MACHINE
LEARNING AND AI PROGRESS, WE
SEE THEM BECOMING VERY
VERSATILE AND WE THINK IT
APPLIES TO A WIDE RANGE OF
FIELDS.  I WANT TO GIVE YOU
TWO EXAMPLES.  FIRST,
ROBOTICS.  AT GOOGLE, A BUNCH
OF 20%ERS DECIDED TO HELP
ROBOTS -- TRAIN ROBOTS TO
PICK UP OBJECTS.  YOU CAN SEE
IT BEHIND ME.  THIS IS NOT
NEW.  YOU USUALLY DO IT BY
WRITING CONTROL SYSTEM CODE.
YOU PROGRAM THE ROBOTS WITH
RULES.  BUT THIS TIME THEY
DECIDE TO USE DEEP LEARNING
TECHNIQUES.  SO YOU CREATE A
CONTINUOUS FEEDBACK CYCLE SO
THAT THE ROBOTS CAN LEARN
HAND-EYE COORDINATION BY
THEMSELVES USING DEEP
LEARNING.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THEY KEEP
DOING IT AND THEY KEEP
LEARNING IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND OVER TIME, THEY GET
BETTER AND THEY EVEN LEARN
NATURAL AND USEFUL BEHAVIORS.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, THE ROBOT IS
NUDGING THE STAPLER AWAY TO
PICK UP THAT YELLOW OBJECT.
WE DIDN'T WRITE THAT RULE.
THE ROBOT LEARNED IT
AUTOMATICALLY USING DEEP
LEARNING.  SO IT'S AN AMAZING
EXAMPLE OF WHAT MACHINE
LEARNING CAN DO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN
HEALTHCARE, DIABETIC
RETINOPATHY IS THE FASTEST
GROWING CAUSE OF BLINDNESS.
IT AFFECTS 4.2 MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE U.S. AND MANY MORE
WORLDWIDE.  TO DETECT IT, YOU
NEED TO DO A SCAN, A SCAN OF
THE EYE LIKE YOU SEE BEHIND
ME AND A HIGHLY TRAINED
DOCTOR CAN DETECT IT.  IF
DETECTED EARLY, THE
TREATMENTS ARE EFFECTIVE.  IF
DETECTED LATE, IT CAUSES
IRREVERSIBLE BLINDNESS.  AND
IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT TO
HAVE HIGHLY TRAINED DOCTORS
AVAILABLE IN MANY PARTS OF
THE WORLD.  SO WE SET OUT TO
WORK WITH A SMALL TEAM OF
ENGINEERS AND DOCTORS AND,
AGAIN, USE DEEP LEARNING AND
STARTED TRAINING ON EYE
SCANS.  AND OVER TIME, OUR
COMPUTER VISION SYSTEMS HAVE
GOTTEN REALLY GOOD AT
DETECTING DIABETIC
RETINOPATHY EARLY.  THIS IS
STILL EARLY, AND THERE'S A
LONG ROAD AHEAD, AND WE'LL
WORK WITH THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY TO GET IT IN THE
HANDS OF AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE.  BUT YOU CAN SEE
THE PROMISE, AGAIN, OF USING
MACHINE LEARNING.
WHEN I HEAR ABOUT
ADVANCEMENTS LIKE THESE, I'M
REMINDED THAT WE LIVE IN AN
EXTRAORDINARY PERIOD FOR
COMPUTING.  WHETHER CLIMATE
CHANGE, HEALTHCARE, OR
EDUCATION, THE MOST IMPORTANT
STRUGGLES ALREADY HAVE
THOUSANDS OF BRILLIANT AND
DEDICATED PEOPLE WORKING TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON ISSUES THAT
AFFECT EVERYONE.
NOW, CONSIDER WHAT THE BEST
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCHERS,
DOCTORS, OR EDUCATORS CAN DO
WITH THE POWER OF MACHINE
LEARNING ASSISTING THEM.
AS YOU HAVE SEEN TODAY, I'M
INCREDIBLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THAT WE ARE MAKING
WITH MACHINE LEARNING AND AI.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE REAL TEST
IS WHETHER HUMANS CAN ACHIEVE
A LOT MORE WITH THE SUPPORT
OF AI ASSISTING THEM.
THINGS PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT TO
BE IMPOSSIBLE MAY, IN FACT,
BE POSSIBLE.  WE LOOK FORWARD
TO BUILDING THIS FUTURE
TOGETHER WITH ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AT
GOOGLE I/O.